TODAY'S JOINT HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON REVENUE
AND TAXATION AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHERE WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING INITIATIVE TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BY CHANGING
THE PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENTS OF
CERTAIN COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTIES. DUE TO
THE STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THING HERE IN THE CHAMBER AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE. IS A FULL
DISTANCE IN PERSON HEARING. IN
THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE OUR MEMBERS AND
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA ATTENDEES SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING ITSELF.
TODAY'S HEARING WITNESSES ARE
TESTIFYING FROM DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS. THE INITIATIVE
PROPONENTS WILL BE MAKING USE
OF A MODERATED PHONE SERVICE.
THE INITIATIVES OPPONENTS WILL
BE MAKING USE OF OUR WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM WHICH
IS LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
WE ALSO HAVE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE MAKING USE OF
THEIR WITNESS VIDEO PROMPTING
ROOM AT THEIR OFFICE. WITNESSES
USING VIDEO CONFERENCING WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIFE
AND ALSO ASK QUESTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY SPECIFICALLY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK. MAY DO SO AT THE END
OF THE HEARING EITHER IN PERSON
OR THROUGH A MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE. IF ANY PERSONAL THE
PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBER WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXPECT THE
CHAMBER ONCE YOU ARE DONE
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CHAMBERS INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS INITIATIVE THE
FIRST FIVE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
ASSEMBLY GALLERY. WHO TESTIFIED
IN THE FIRST FIVE INDIVIDUALS
IN THE MODERATED PHONE LINE Q.
WILL BE PERMITTED TO TESTIFY UP
TO ONE MINUTE. THERE AFTER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS WILL BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION. THE
SAME PROCESS WILL BE USED FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS FINISH.
FIVE INDIVIDUALS AND ASSEMBLY
GALLERY IN THE FIRST FIVE
INDIVIDUALS ON THE MODERATE
PHONE LINE WILL BE PERMITTED TO
TESTIFY FOR UP TO ONE MINUTE.
THEREAFTER ADDITIONAL PUNDITS
WILL BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO STATE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND RATE THE REITERATE THEIR
OPPOSITION STANCE. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
SOME ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
YOU'RE CALLING IN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO SO AS THE FINAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BEGIN
THEIR TESTIMONY. THE OPERATOR
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN Q. BASED
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THIS INITIATIVE. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
MEAN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY ON THIS INITIATIVE
YOUR MAIN ON A LIVE LINE. AND
WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF INTO
YOUR CALL TO SPEAK. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH EMAIL
THE EMAIL ADDRESS IS A R. E. V.
AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
THIS ADDRESS IS ALSO POST ON
THE ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEES WEBSITE.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL FACE.
WITH ALL OF THOSE HAVE CAN BE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ASSEMBLY LINE
KILEY WILL BE APPOINTED TO FILL
IN. FOR REPUBLICAN VACANCY ON
THE ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE FOR THIS
HEARING ONLY. THE. OKAY HI SO
WE'LL START WITH OPENING
REMARKS FROM THE TWO CHAIRS ALL
START THE PROCESS IS SHAPED
HORNS PROPERTY TAX SYSTEM WITH
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. AND TO
MARKET VALUE BASED ASSESSMENTS
NOW POSSIBLE TRANSFORMATION OF
THE SYSTEM THROUGH THE INITIAL
PROCESS PRESENTS ITSELF WITH
THE PROPOSED PROPOSAL TO RETURN
CERTAIN COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTIES TO A
MARKET VALUE BASIS. THERE ARE
NUMBER CONCERN RAISED BY BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE TODAY'S
INFORMAL HEARING LAW ALLOWS TO
HEAR FROM BOTH THE INITIATIVE
PROPONENTS. AND OPPONENTS
FOLLOWING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
INITIATIVE FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THIS HEARING
WILL ALSO OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO WEIGH IN ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MEMBERS OF
BOTH COMMITTEES AND THE
SPEAKERS PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING. AT THIS POINT
I WILL TURN THE MICROPHONE OVER
TO MY CO CHAIR FOR OPENING
REMARKS. THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
JOINING A TODAY. FOR A- HERE TO
DISCUSS AN AND YOU. THAT COULD
BE SENT TO THE VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER'S GENERAL ELECTION.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
A LIVELY DISCUSSION FROM OUR
PANELISTS AND TO GAINING A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
VOTER INITIATIVE. YOU ALL
CERTAINLY HAVE YOUR WORK CUT
OUT FOR YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR REVENUE IN TAX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CURE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOINING US TODAY. AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP TO ANY MEMBERS JOINING US
TODAY THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
I WOULD ASK HOWEVER THAT WE
LEAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR AFTER I
GUESS HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT. OUR ANY OF THE
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT OF ANY SORT. SEEING
NONE THE WILL MOVE ONE- TO- THE
INTRODUCTION OF- LA. JOINING US
TODAY FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S ANALYST'S OFFICE IS A
VIDEO A CONFERENCE ROOM IS
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
BRIAN MUELLER WILL BE PROVIDING
AN OVERVIEW OF THE INITIATIVE.
PLEASE THERE ARE CONNECTED TO
THE LA OWES VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GRANULAR WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEES
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
IN YOUR HEARING TODAY- WE WILL
BE PRESENTING AN OVERVIEW OF
THE MEASURE AND OUR ESTIMATES
OF THE MEASURES OF FISCAL
IMPACTS I WANT TO START OFF A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT- BUT OUR
OFFICES ROLE IN THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS- WE HAVE- AS A
STATUTORY ROOMS PROCESS THAT WE
PROVIDE AN OBJECTIVE. IMPARTIAL
DESCRIPTION OF THE OF THE
MEASURE AND IT'S FISCAL IMPACTS
FOR THE VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE
AND UNDER THIS SOMEWHAT NARROW
ROLE WE DON'T THINK OF THIS ON
THE MERITS OF MEASURES AND FOR
THAT REASON I WILL BE ABLE TO
SPEAK THOSE TYPES OF ISSUES IN
THE HEARING TODAY BUT YOU DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF PANELISTS WILL
FOLLOW. AFTER ME WHO ARE BETTER
POSITIONED TO SPEAK TO THOSE
ISSUES BEFORE GETTING INTO THE
MEASURE I WANTED TO JUST
BRIEFLY GIVE A BIT OF A
BACKGROUND ON CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING PROPERTY TAX SYSTEM.
PROPERTY TAXES ARE THE SO
LARGEST GOVERNMENT REVENUE
SOURCE IN AND IT IS EXCLUSIVELY
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT REVENUE
SOURCE PROVIDING ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
CITIES. COUNTY SCHOOLS AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. THERE'S
SEVERAL CLASSES A PROPERTY THAT
ARE TAXED ON THE PROPERTY TAX
TO A MAIN CATEGORIES ARE REAL
PROPERTY WHICH OUR LAND AND
BUILDINGS. ANOTHER MAJOR
CATEGORY. BUSINESS PERSONAL
PROPERTY WHICH IS ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT BUSINESSES ON LIKE
EQUIPMENT AND MACHINERY AND
COMPUTERS AND FURNITURE- THESE
TWO CATEGORIES OF PROPERTY OR
TAX-DIFFERENTLY UNDER OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM- REAL PROPERTY
IS TAXED BASED ON THE SYSTEM
THAT WAS CREATED BY PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN THAT IS ITS- ITS
TAXABLE VALUE OR ASSESSED VALUE
IS SET BASED ON ITS- PURCHASE
PRICE WHEN IT'S PURCHASED. AT
THE ASSESSOR SENTENCED ACTUAL
VALUE BASED ON WHAT IT WAS BUT
I WHAT WAS PAID FOR AND- EACH
YEAR THEREAFTER THAT TACKLE
VALUES ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION
BY UP TO TWO PERCENT. THE NAME
OF THE PROPERTY IS SOLD AGAIN
IT'S TAX WITHOUT USE RESET TO
ITS NEW PURCHASE PRICE. UNDER
THIS SYSTEM- MOST PROPERTIES
ARE TAX- IT'S SOMETHING BELOW
THEIR MARKET VALUE OR WHAT THEY
COULD BE PAID FOR THIS IS
BECAUSE- THE MARKET VALUE MOST
PROPERTIES GROWS. MORE THAN 2%
A YEAR. BUSINESS PERSONAL.
INCOME IS TACK BASED ON ITS
pSOLD FOR TODAY- SO TURNING TO
HOW THE INITIATIVE WOULD CHANGE
THIS PROJECT SYSTEM IT WOULD
MAKE CHANGES BOTH TO. A REAL
PROPERTY ASSESSMENT AND TO
BUSINESS PERSONAL PROPERTY
ASSESSMENT. OUR FIRST THE
MEASURE WOULD- SHIFT COMMERCIAL
AND INDUSTRIAL REAL PROPERTY TO
MARKET VALUE TAXATION. OF THIS
CHANGE WOULD BE PHASED IN OVER
A NUMBER OF YEARS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND THE
CHANGE WOULD NOT START UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FOUR-
PROPERTIES THAT ARE USED
PRIMARILY BY BUSINESSES WITH.
FIFTY OR FEWER EMPLOYEES AND
THAT MEET CERTAIN OTHER
CRITERIA PROPERTIES USED FOR
HOUSING AND AGRICULTURAL LAND-
WOULD REMAIN OF THE PROP
THIRTEEN SYSTEM WOULD BE TAX
BASED ON THEIR ORIGINAL
PURCHASE PRICE. US SOME
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL
PROPERTIES ALSO WOULD BE
EXEMPTED FROM THE SHIP THE
MARKET VALUE TAXATION UNDER THE
MEASURE SPECIFICALLY. OF THOSE
PROPERTIES THAT ARE OWNED BY A
PERSON OR BUSINESS THAT OWNS-
IN TOTAL- THREE MILLION OR LESS
IN PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA-
WOULD BE EXEMPTED FROM THE
SHIFT TO MARKET VALUE TAXATION.
THE MEASURE ALSO PROPOSES
CHANGES THE BUSINESS PERSONAL
PROPERTY THAT WOULD REDUCE
ACTUAL VALUE OF HIS PERSONAL
PROPERTY BY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR EACH BUSINESS. IF
A BUSINESS HAS LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
BUSINESS PERSONAL PROPERTY THAN
THEY WOULD PAY NO TAX ON THOSE
ITEMS. IN ADDITION ALL PERSONAL
TAXES WOULD BE ELIMINATED FOR-
BUSINESSES WITH MORE THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES AND THAT MEANS. A
CERTAIN OTHER CRITERIA THEN
TURNING OUR- OF THE FOR OF THE
MEASURE THE LAW. THE FACT IS
FROM THE SHIFT OF COMMERCIAL
AND INDUSTRIAL REAL PROPERTY TO
MARKET VALUE TAXATION. MOST
OWNERS OF COMMERCIAL REAL
PROPERTY WOULD. FACE HIGHER
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS UNDER THE
SHIFT THAT IS BECAUSE MOST OF
THOSE PROPERTIES TAX OF VALUES
NOW FALL BELOW THEIR MARKET
VALUE. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
THESE HIGHER TAXES WE PHASED IN
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS. WE
THINK THOUGH BY AROUND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE MOST- COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY OWNERS WOULD BE PAYING
A HIGHER TAXES. OF BEGINNING
AROUND THIS TIME- TOTAL NEW
REVENUE GENERATED FROM THE
SHIFT. WOULD BE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN EIGHT BILLION AND
TWELVE I'VE FOUGHT DOLLARS PER
YEAR. I WE WOULD KNOW THAT THIS
IS A NEW REVENUE STREAM WOULD
BE MORE VOLATILE THAN THE
EXISTING PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE MORE
CLOSELY TIED. TO FLUCTUATIONS.
IT'S AND OF SOMEWHAT OFFSETTING
THE INCREASE FROM THE SHIP IN A
REAL PROPERTY TO WOULD BE A
REDUCTION IN THIS PERSONAL
TAXES PAID BY BUSINESSES WE
ESTIMATE THAT UNDER THE
MEASURES PROVISIONS BUSINESS
PERSONAL PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS
WOULD BE REDUCED BY SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. THE MEASURE ALSO SETS
ASIDE FROM THE NEW- REVENUE
MONIES TO COVER VARIOUS COSTS
RELATED TO THE MEASURE- THIS
INCLUDES PROVIDING SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
TO COUNTING IS. TO COVER THEIR
COSTS OF ADMINISTERING THE
MEASURE. SO AFTER OFFSETTING-
THE BUSINESS PERSONAL PROPERTY
REDUCTIONS AND THE COST OF THE
MEASURE WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
MEASURE WOULD PROVIDE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN SIX POINT FIVE AND
ELEVEN POINT FIVE. BILLION IN A
NEW PROPERTY TAX REVENUE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SCHOOLS
EACH YEAR- THIS FUNDING WOULD
BE SPLIT 60% TO CITIES COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS. ARE WITH
EACH PARTICULAR LOCALITY IS-
SHARE BEING VARYING BASED ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS AND IT WOULD
VERY ACROSS REGIONS OF THE
STATE AS WELL. THE REMAINING
40% WOULD GO TO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THOSE
ALLOCATIONS INDIVIDUAL
ENTITIES. WITH LARGELY. I
REFLECT THE PEOPLE ALLOCATIONS
AND ARE MADE UNDER THE STATE'S
EXISTING LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WITHIN THAT
INTRODUCTION OF THE MEASURE I'D
BE HAPPY TO. QUESTIONS. SEASON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. YEAH
HELLO I USED TO BE ON THE
BUNDLE CITY COUNCIL AND I KNOW
THAT OUR CITY IS A- KNOWN LOW
PROPERTY TAX CITY SO WE GET
VERY LITTLE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE. AND I WANT TO KNOW
THAT WHETHER OR NOT TO ALL
GOVERNMENTS OF SCHOOLS RECEIVE
AN EQUAL SHAREOF THE NEW TAX
REVENUE FROM THIS MEASURE. WELL
THE MAJORITY OF THE NEW TAX
REVENUE CODE OF. MORE WEALTHY
JURISDICTIONS WHERE THE HIGH
VALUE PROPERTIES ARE LOCATED.
YES THERE'S- KIND OF THEIRS AND
AS I MENTIONED THERE'S A NUMBER
OF FACTORS THAT WILL AFFECT THE
ALLOCATION TWO KEY FACTORS ARE.
WHAT IS EACH LOCALITIES CURRENT
SHARE OF THE PROPERTY TAX. AND
HOW MUCH NEW REVENUE WILL BE
GENERATED- BY THE SHIFT TO
MARKET VALUE TAXATION FOR
PROPERTIES WITHIN THAT
JURISDICTION. SO IN GENERAL
RIGHT NOW IF THEY- JURISDICTION
IS RECEIVING A HIGHER SHARE OF
THE PROPERTY TAX- THEY'RE
LIKELY TO SEE MORE OF A HIGHER
SHARE THIS MEASURE. AND ALSO IF
THE JURISDICTION HAS A NUMBER
OF- OF HIGH VALUE COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES- THAT. WOULD RECEIVE
A SIGNIFICANT- UPWARD A
REVISION IN THEIR TAX
ASSESSMENT THEN THAT
JURISDICTION ALSO WOULD
RECEIVE- A LARGER SHARE. ANYONE
ELSE HAVE A QUESTION THE SUMMER
KILEY. I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S US HEIGHT ON
SUMMARY FOR THIS INITIATIVE
AND- WHETHER YOU THINK IT.
CAPTURES THE ESSENCE OF- WHAT
FOLKS ARE BEING ASKED TO VOTE
ON IN IN A NEUTRAL BALANCED WAY.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK I CAN
PROVIDE ANY COMMENT ON THAT I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF OUTSIDE
OF. THE CHARGES BEEN GIVEN TO
OUR OFFICE ON THIS INITIATIVE.
THE LA I WILL BE DOING ITS OWN
SUMMARY RIGHT. WELL WE PROVIDE
A SUMMARY ANALYSIS THAT SHOWS
UP IN THE VOTER INFORMATION
GUIDE YES. OKAY DO YOU
IDENTIFIED ANY DIFFERENCES IN
THE WAY IT'S BEEN DESCRIBED IN
THE- TITLE SUMMARY AND HOW YOUR
OFFICE WILL IS PRIVATE. HI I
DON'T THINK I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. SERENA RELIVING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND-
THIS IS THIS MAY AS WELL BE OUT
OF THE PURVIEW OF WHAT THE LA
IS OFFICE WAS LOOKING OUT
MISTER YOU ARE SO. I APOLOGIZE
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM PALMDALE
DID RAISE AN ISSUE ABOUT
PROPERTY TAX ALLOCATIONS AND
INEQUITIES THAT DIFFERENT-
CITIES HAVE. BECAUSE OF THEIR
LOW ALLOCATION- THAT MAYBE WAS
FROZEN IN TIME BY EIGHTY EIGHT
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES BUT
WE'RE CITIES THAT ARE RIGHT
NEXT TO EACH OTHER ARE
RETAINING. FAR DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY FROM- PROPERTY
TAX DOLLARS- THAT ARE RIGHT
NEXT TO EACH OTHER DELIVERING
SIMILAR SERVICES. AND WHETHER
IN ANY OF THE THEIR REVIEW OF
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE I ARE
THERE WAYS TO MODERNIZE WHAT AB
EIGHT DID TO CREATE GREATER
EQUITY BETWEEN COMMUNITIES
THANKS. I THINK THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS PROVIDED TO AMONG
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. THEN A KIND OF A
HOTLY DEBATED TOPIC FOR REALLY
DECADES FRONT PRETTY MUCH EVERY
SENSE PROP THIRTEEN WAS PUT IN
PLACE- AND THERE ARE NUMBER OF
KIND OF CHALLENGES TO REFORMING
THAT IN TERMS OF- IN SOME SENSE
IT'S A- IT'S A ZERO SUM GAME
THAT YOU KNOW REVENUE SHIFTED
FROM TWO ONE YOUR STATION HAS
TO COME FROM SOME OTHER PLACE
AND THAT'S MADE IT- KIND OF A
DIFFICULT AREA OF REFORM- WE
DID NOT. IN IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THE ANALYSIS FOR THIS
MEASURE WE DID NOT CONSIDER- AS
I MENTIONED KIND OF THE POLICY
MERITS OF THE MEASURES DECISION
TO- ALLOCATE THE NEW REVENUE
CONSISTENT WITH THE EXISTING.
PROPERTY TAX ALLOCATION SYSTEM.
SOMEONE WILL TELL. YES HAS THE-
LA- FACTORED IN TO THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL FORMULA HERE THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT THAT RAISING
TAXES ON COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE
WILL HAVE ESPECIALLY WITH COVE
ID NINETEEN IMPACTS ON THE
WHOLE ECONOMY AND MANY MANY
COMPANIES WILL BE DOING REMOTE
WORK INSTEAD OF ANY OFFICES FOR
SOCIAL SPACE IN A TETRA AND
ALSO HAVE YOU FACTORED IN. THE
EXODUS OF. OUT OF CALIFORNIA OF
MANY OF COMMERCIAL ENTERPRISES
AND BECAUSE THIS IS PHASED IN.
IF I OWNED LARGE AMOUNTS OF
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY WHICH I
DON'T. I WOULD BE GETTING NOT A
DODGER REAL FAST BEFORE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE HAVE YOU FACTORED
ANY OF THAT IS. THANK YOU. IT
YES THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE
DID IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING OUR ANALYSIS WE DID
REVIEW THE AVAILABLE RESEARCH
AND EVIDENCE ON THE POTENTIAL
FAX- OF. A MEASURE LIKE THIS
ON- BUSINESS ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA- WE DID REVIEW THAT
IN INCORPORATE THAT AS BEST WE
COULD IN OUR ANALYSIS- ON YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
CODED- I THINK THAT THERE'S A
NUMBER OF UNCERTAINTIES THAT
ARE INHERENT IN- THE POTENTIAL
REVENUE THE COULD BE RAISING
THIS MEASURE I THINK YOU
POINTED OUT ONE SIGNIFICANT
ONE. AND WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
INCORPORATE- THAT UNCERTAINTY
IN THE FACT THAT WE PRESENTED
QUITE A WIDE RANGE OF POTENTIAL
REVENUE UP WITH. WITH ESTIMATE
AND THAT IS JUST DEGREE
ATTEMPTING TO. BOTH THE FOR
FLUCTUATIONS THE MIKE FROM NOW
ECONOMICS I IS AS A KIND OF AN
X. THINGS LIKE BUT. THANK YOU A
ASSEMBLY MAY. CHIU FROM. I
THANK YOU MISTER OF MADONNA ARE
THE ARE YOU PEARL TO I THINK
THIS IS A TIME TO DO THE IMP OF
COBRA NINETEEN HAS BEEN OVER.
AND WHILE DELAY TAKE TO WHAT WE
ARE IS TO REDUCE CUT TO PROGRAM
IN OUR BUDGET THE REVENUE OF
THIS IN THE WELL HOW TO COME.
THROUGH VERY DIFFICULT TIME AND
VERY THE. OUR REQUEST FOR THE
IS OF I FOR DIZZY IS CA OF LOW
THE IF THE FIELD FOR COME THAT
BEING A ROCK AROUND FULL TIME
VERSUS THE NEW COMP WOULD JUST
OF PURCHASE CARE LESS. IN THE
ROOT. SO WHAT. THE IMPLEMENTERS.
AT THE- IS TO STEP THE BY THE
VOTER. WHO WOULD THE LOWER. OF
THE- PROPERTY TAX. PULLED SMALL
BIZ IF THE NEWER BEST. WHO
PEOPLE MUCH CAN ALSO. THE
INCREASE AND TAX. FOR THE
REDUCTION IN NEW YORK A- I
DON'T KNOW THAT I GET SPEAK TO
IN BUSINESS ARE THAT OVER. THE
IN THE BUSINESS PERSONAL
BECAUSE WHAT ALL. PARTIALLY THE
INK TAX THAT WOULD BE PAID ON
REAL THERE BE SOME BUSINESS AS
YOU MAY THAT MAYBE JUST
PURCHASE REAL PROPERTY THAT
HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESS PERSONAL
PROPERTY THEY- BUSINESSES AND
THAT ROOM STANDS MAY NOT FACE
OPENING A TAXING. FOR HAVE SOME
TAX A UNDER THE MEASURE I YOU
KNOW I CAN'T SPEAKS TO YOUR
BUSINESSES ARE FROM SAN LOW.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTION
THANK YOU MISTER YOU IF YOU'RE
PRESSED I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. HOW WILL THIS
INITIATIVE IMPACT AGRICULTURAL
PROPERTY INCLUDING ANY TANGIBLE
PROPERTY NOT CLASSIFIED AS LAND
SUCH AS AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT.
YEAH SO THE MEASURE- VERY
CLEARLY- EXEMPTS AGRICULTURAL
LAND FROM THE SHIP TO MARKET
VALUE TAXATION- AS FOR OTHER
KINDS OF PROPERTY THAT MIGHT BE
RELATED TO AGRICULTURE- IF
THOSE PROPERTIES HAVE A-
COMMERCIAL USE- THAN THIS
MEASURE LIKELY WOULD SHIFT
THOSE PROPERTIES TO A MARKET
VALUE TAXATION. AND THEN SO
JUST TO BE CLEAR ALSO IS IF
THIS INITIATIVE PASSES THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT GOES TO
SCHOOLS ADD TO EXISTING LEVELS
OF EDUCATIONAL FUNDING OR WOULD
IT REPLACE EXISTING FUNDING.
BASICALLY HOW'S IT GOING TO
AFFECT PROP NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEES. YES THANK YOU I
THINK I COULD HAVE BEEN MORE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT IN MY COMMENTS
THIS- THE FUNDING THAT WOULD GO
TO SCHOOLS. I WOULD BE
SUPPLEMENTARY TO WHATEVER
FUNDING SCHOOLS RECEIVE UNDER
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THOSE OF THE
END OF MY QUESTIONS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE. YOU CAN
START WITH A PATH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY TODAY WE HAVE
THREE PRIMARY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK WITH US REPRESENTING
INITIATIVES PROPONENTS CAROLINE
GRAY WITH THE FRESNO METROPLEX
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND CHAMBER
FOUNDATION. TIM GATE WITH BLUE
SKY CONSULTING AND SASHA COLOR
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. WITH
ALLOCATED A TOTAL OF FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR THE PROPONENTS I
WOULD ASK THE MODERATOR TO
CONNECT US FIRST WITH CAROLINE
GRAY. WITH THE FRESNO METRO
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND
WE HAVE TO LINE OPEN FOR
CAROLINE GREAT PLEASE PROCEED.
HELLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MEETING IT IS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AND YOU MAY BEGIN AS
SOON AS YOU ALREADY. THANK YOU.
THE FACT THAT CHAMBER COMMERCE
DEDICATE TO. THE OF THE GREATER
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THIRTY CREATION OF
OPPORTUNITIES ADVOCATE BE IN
BUSINESS ECONOMIC MOBILITY. ON
IT. I'M PRACTICE BUSINESS AND
CULTURE. I HIGHER. AND
FINANCIAL JUST HAVE THAT THOSE
BE IN EQUITY ALREADY. FOR IS
AND ADDED TO THE CRIED THAT
COMMUNITY THAT COLOR ARE. FACE
DAY. WE NEED FOR INITIAL AT AND
NEED FEEL THAT SMALL BUSINESS
AT THE END AND OTHER COMMUNITY
OF COLOR ALL RIGHT FRONTLINE
THAT THAT MAKE AND HAVE HAD THE
HARDEST TIME AFFECT THE HELL
THAT THEY DESPERATELY. AND THE
STANDS TO LOSE THEM OUT DON'T
MANY OF WHOM NEVER ABLE TO GET
EQUITABLE FINANCE FROM BANKS
OFTEN ON THE FINANCING IF YOU
NEED THE- OPEN YOUR DOOR AND IN
TURN THEY FROM YOUR P. EIGHT
AFTER SHE ACT WHICH AND DIDN'T
GIVE WITH TIME AND TALENTS. HIM
GAUGE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC I'M A CO
FOUNDER THE BLUE SKY CONSULTING
GROUP PRIOR TO THAT. THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FOR THE
STATE FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND AND TWO. I
BEGAN MY CAREER WITH THE STATE
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WERE AT THE PROPERTY TAX
AND LOCAL FISCAL RELIEF
ASSIGNMENT. OVER MY NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO THE STATE
I ALSO SERVED AS CHIEF
CONSULTANT TO THE ASSEMBLY WAYS
AND MEANS COMMITTEE AND WHAT
THE- THIS CALL BECAUSE- TO TWO
PRESIDENTS PRO TEM. OF THE
STATE SENATE AND I'D LIKE TO
SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS WITH YOU
ABOUT WHY SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FIRST IS SO
CRITICAL. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ACCOUNTED FOR ABOUT 45% OF ALL
PROPERTY TAXES IN CALIFORNIA
COMPARED 255% PAID BY
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES. TODAY
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ACCOUNT FOR
JUST 28% OF CALIFORNIA PROPERTY
TAXES. COMPARED 272% PAID BY
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY. CHANGE
PROP THIRTEEN PROPERTY TAXES AS
A PERCENT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REVENUE FELL FROM 55228% AND AT
THE SAME TIME FEES CHARGES AND
OTHER TAXES HAVE INCREASED FROM
28% 251% OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
REVENUES AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND PROPERTY
TAXES PAID BY LARGE CORPORATE
PROPERTIES LANGUAGE. CAUSING
THE REST OF US IN EFFECT TO BE
NICKEL AND DIME. THE BILL HAS
SHARE. OF STATE AND LOCAL TAXES
IN CALIFORNIA IS BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AS IS THE
RATIO OF BUSINESS TAXES TO
BENEFITS RECEIVED FROM STATE
AND LOCAL SPENDING. IN SHORT ON
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
ARE PAYING LESS AND GETTING
MOE AND RETURN COMPARED TO.
BUSINESSES IN OTHER STATES.
DESPITE ROBUST ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND A SURGEON ON PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE PER CAPITA CITY AND
COUNTY REVENUE AND CALIFORNIA
FELL FROM. SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT TO SIX HUNDRED FORTY
DOLLARS TODAY I NEARLY 20%
DECLINE. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN CALIFORNIA WAS SEVENTH IN
THE NATION IN PER PUPIL
SPENDING. TODAY IT IS THIRTY
SEVEN. EVEN AS HOMEOWNERS AND
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
SHOULDER GREATER BURDEN TO
COMPENSATE FOR THE SUBSIDIES TO
LARGE BUSINESS PROPERTY OWNERS.
VITAL PUBLIC INVESTMENTS HAVE
SUFFERED. IN FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SPENDING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS THIRTY SEVEN
AMONG ALL STATE. SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FIRST EXPAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
CAPACITY FOR SCHOOLS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. LIKE SPENDING THE
TAX BASE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FIRST WILL MAKE IT
POSSIBLE TO PAY OFF LOCAL BOND
MEASURES PAID BY VOTER APPROVED
PROPERTY TAX RATE OVERRIDES
MORE QUICKLY AND MAKE FUTURE
INVESTMENTS LESS COSTLY FOR
HOMEOWNERS SCHOOLS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS OPENS THE DOOR
TO A BAND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS BY SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SCHOOLS IN THESE
FIRST IS DELIBERATELY DESIGNED
TO BOOST CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS. THE MEASURE
ALUMINIZED BUSINESS PERSONAL
PROPERTY TAXES ON EQUIPMENT AND
FIXTURES LIKE MANUFACTURING
EQUIPMENT COMPUTERS AND SERVERS
ON THE FIRST FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF PROPERTY
FOR ALL BUSINESSES AND
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. THIS TAX CUT MEANS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES. WILL EITHER
PAY NO INCREASE A RECEIVE A TAX
REDUCTION AS A RESULT OF THE
MEASURE. HOME BASED BUSINESSES
WHICH MAKE UP ABOUT 50% OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS. ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ARE
SPECIFICALLY EXEMPT FROM THE
ASSESSMENT BY THE MEASURE LIKE
EVERY OTHER RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY AND WOULD RECEIVE A
TAX CUT FOR THE PROPERTY TAX
THEY PAY ON THEIR BUSINESS
PERSONAL PROPERTY. TAXPAYERS
WHO PROPERTIES ARE VALUED AT
LESS THAN THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- EXPLICITLY EXEMPT AND
ENJOY THE SAME BENEFITS. SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT RENT ALSO
RECEIVE THE BENEFIT OF THE
PERSONAL PROPERTY TAX CUT AND
ARE PROTECTED FROM REASSESSMENT
BAY- PATH THROUGH BY THE FAITH
IN PROVISIONS OF THE MEASURE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MEASURE
DELAYED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE. AND
CRAFT A FAITH IN PLAN AND THEN
A MINIMUM OF THREE ADDITIONAL
YEARS BEFORE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION AND MORE IF THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINES THAT THE
PURPOSE. BECAUSE OF THIS SMALL
BUSINESS RENTERS HAVE YEARS TO
ADJUST BEFORE LANDLORDS.
EXPERIENCE REASSESSMENT. THE
RESULT OF IT IS A MEASURE THAT
REWARD SMALL BUSINESS
INVESTMENT AND PLACES A LITTLE
IF ANY ADDITIONAL TAX BURDEN ON
SMALL BUSINESSES. EXACTLY THE
KIND OF APPROACH WE NEED COMING
OUT OF THIS CURRENT CRISIS. I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS TWO STATEMENTS
BY THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- THE FIRST OF THESE WAS
THEIR STATEMENT THAT- MOST
PROPERTIES WILL SEE A TAX
INCREASE BY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. OUR ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT
94% OF THE REVENUE WOULD COME
FROM ONLY 10% OF THE MOST UNDER
SAYS COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
PROPERTIES IN THE STATE. IN
ADDITION- THERE WAS A QUESTION
OF THE ANALYSTS ABOUT
AGRICULTURE AND THE TREATMENT
OF AGRICULTURAL PROPERTY WOULD
LARGELY REMAIN AS UNDER CURRENT
LAW. LAND CROPS BARNES AND SO
FORTH. WOULD REMAIN. AS TREATED
UNDER CURRENT LAW AND WOULD NOT
BE AFFECTED BY THIS MEASURE.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I'D
LIKE TO TURN THE PRESENTATION
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE SASHA
CUTLER. I WOULD NOW ASK THE
MODERATOR TO CONNECT US WITH
SASHA CUTLER WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
WE HAVE TO LINE OPEN FOR SASHA
CUTLER YOU MAY PROCEED. YES I
AM I DOCTOR CUTLER AND- I'M NOT
I APPRECIATE- THE FAMILY
MEMBERS THE WILL ALLOWING ME
TED AT THE FIVE BY BY TELEPHONE
ALTHOUGH THAT PUTS ME AT A
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE- NURSES
SUCH AS MYSELF ARE. ODD NOT
ONLY- THE MOST TRUSTED
PROTECTION WERE ALSO THE BETTER
LOOKING SO YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO.
TAKE A LOOK AT ME- I'VE I'VE I
HAVE A PHD IN NURSING THAT I
OBTAINED FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO- IN
AND THAT WAS ABOUT-
TUBERCULOSIS TREATMENT THAT
WOULD BE DONE BY THE IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHERE I WORKED-
FOR MANY YEARS AS WELL I BEGAN
WORKING IN. THE AIDS EPIDEMIC
IN THE ADULT DAVID- IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SO CURRENT EVENTS
REALLY TO ME NOW WITH. THERE
THE BEES WITHOUT BACK. NOW WITH
BAND THERE'S NO FRAME THE GREED
THE LAW AFTER LOG THAT WE HAVE
GOING ON. AND NOW HAVE BEEN
PEOPLE ARE WONDER WHETHER THEIR
PATIENT ARE STILL TO BE THERE
WHEN THEY COME BACK AGAIN- I
HAVE BEEN I HAVE BEEN WORKING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC- BOTH-
FRONTLINE- PROVIDING- CASTING.
THAT PATIENTS IN THEIR HOMES
ORIGINALLY- WHEN THAT ONE OUT
IT BEGAN IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
NOW I'M WORKING ON THE NURSE
ADVICE LINE AT THE HOSPITAL I'M
AFRAID OF GETTING THE DISEASE
AND I'M AFRAID OF GIVING IT TO
MY FAMILY- AND- WHAT MY PATIENT.
YEAH MY COWORKERS CURRENTLY MY
COULD DURATION IS- IN THE IN
THE CALL CENTER AND IN THE CALL
CENTER- THERE WAS ONE OF OCT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAME INFECTED
AND JOINED THE MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE WORKERS
WHO ARE NOW HAVE BEEN INFECTED
WITH KOBE NINETEEN AND THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND THAT NUMBER
WE CAN'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THEM
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF. A
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
BUT THAT COULD BE VERY MANY OF
THEM BUT BECAUSE OF THE CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING AND- STAFFING- I
WITHOUT WORK IN OUR FACILITY I
AM NOW WORKING IN A ROW- YEAH
I'M UNABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT IT
BETWEEN- WE MIGHT HELP AND
THEIR CO WORKERS WE'RE SITTING
IN. THE VENTILATION A ALL. OPEN
THE WINDOWS AND THAT ARE NOT
HERE GO THROUGH THEIR ON THEIR
NO THERE'S NO CANNOT AVAIL. AND
THERE HAVE BEEN- WE HAVE BEEN
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO RATION
THE EQUIPMENT AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR DONATIONS. FROM THE PUBLIC
FOR PERSONALIZED PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THIS IS AN A COLOSSAL
FAILURE OF THE PUBLIC HELD UP
CALIFORNIA THAT I'M VERY PROUD
TO WORK WITH. WE NEED HELP WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THIS- WE
HAVE- WE NOW HAVE WE NOW HAVE
THIS SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
FIRST WHICH IS HOW I KNOW THIS.
IS MEASURE ON BECAUSE I'M NOT A
I'M NOT A TAX EXPERT ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT AND WE
COULD REALLY USE TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS- SHOULD BE HELPING THAT
SCHOOLS AND- AND HEALTHCARE IS
WELL. THE COMMISSION SHALL
ROLLED DOWN THERE WE HAVE- THAT
WE HAVE TO FOR SALE- AND IT'S
REALLY UNCONSCIONABLE THERE WE
LITERALLY PUTTING OUR ON THE
LINE. I WOULD CORPORATION THE
STATE ARE BENEFITING FROM TACK
LOOP. OTHER DRAINING REAP FROM
LOCAL. AND SCHOOL. I'VE NEVER
CARED FOR A CORPORATION BEFORE
I CARED FOR HUMAN BEING. WE'RE
COUNTING ON YOU TO WIN BACK
THEN POPPED NOT CORPORATE TAX
LOOPHOLES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION MEMBERS
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. AND CO
CHAIR. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS FOR SHOULD
THE I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS- MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES LEASE THE
PROPERTY WHERE THEY CONDUCT
BUSINESS. COULD CERTAIN SMALL
BUSINESSES STILL BE AFFECTED IF
THE PROPERTY WHERE THEY CONDUCT
BUSINESS DOES NOT FALL WITHIN
THE SMALL BUSINESS DOES
BUSINESS EXEMPTION. THIS IS TEN
GAUGE I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION- SO THE AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF. SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
OUR OTHER HOME BASED FOR ALL
THE RIGHT PROPERTY A RELATIVELY
SMALLER PROPORTION RENT THEIR
PROPERTY. AND PART OF THE
DESIGN OF THE MEASURE WAS TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TIME FOR
THOSE. RENTERS BUSINESS RENTERS
TO NEGOTIATE- RENEGOTIATE THEIR
LEASES BEFORE THE PROPERTY IS
REASSESS SO- THE LEGISLATURE AS
I MENTIONED MY COMMENT
BASICALLY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
EXTEND A PHASE IN PERIOD- UNDER
THE MEASURE IT'S A MINIMUM OF
THREE YEARS- BUT THEY CAN
EXPAND THAT FURTHER. THE
INTENTION OTHER THE MEASURE
WOULD BE- TO FOCUS ON
PROPERTIES WERE THE GREATEST
DISPARITY IN TERMS OF- THE GAP
BETWEEN ASSESSED VALUE IN
MARKET VALUE AND SO. MANY OF
THE SMALL BUSINESSES WOULD WRAP
WOULD HAVE AS A STAY A
SIGNIFICANT PERIOD OF TIME IN
WHICH TO RENEGOTIATE THEIR
LEASES. CURRENTLY THE LEASES
THAT THEY PAY YOU ARE
DETERMINED BY THE MARKET. AND
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY-
BUSINESS HAS A VERY OLD-
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT I DON'T
BASE YOUR VALUE UNDER
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. AND AS
CONSEQUENCES LOW PROPERTY TAXES.
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD THEY'RE NOT
PASSING THOSE SAVINGS THROUGH
TO THEIR RENTERS BECAUSE- RENTS
ARE DETERMINED BY THE MARKET.
AND SO WHEN THAT KIND OF ORDER-
IS RE ASSESSED BUSINESSES THAT
RAN FROM THAT ORDER WILL BE IN
A POSITION TO SHOP AROUND IN
THE MARKET- BECAUSE THE MARKET
IN EFFECT IS WHAT HAS WHAT HAS
DETERMINED- ACOSTA THE RENT NOT
THAT- PROPERTY TAX RATE THAT
THE OWNER IS PAYING. OKAY THANK
YOU MY LAST QUESTION IF IT OVER.
THIS IS CAROLYN GRAY IF I MAY
I'D JUST LIKE TO ADD ON I'M IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION
THREE- I THINK THAT THIS
QUESTION LEAD TO AND HOW IT WAS
JUST ANSWERED- THAT NEEDS TO.
BE UNDER SCORED IT BECAUSE-
BILLS THAT LANDLORDS THAT HAVE
PROPERTIES FOR THEIR PAIN LOWER
TAX AND THEY ARE NOT RULING
INVESTING IN THE COMMUNITY AND
I THINK THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE
DECADE THE DEGREE THAT MAN IN
THE UNITY AND ESPECIALLY THOSE.
IN BLACK AND OTHER. COLOR AND
SO IT WILL LAST CRITICAL
SERVICE GAS SUCH AS EMERGENCY
BUT BY PUBLIC HEALTH OR- SCHOOL
ON THE THEIR OWN AND FUNDING
DOING MY PART TO THE BROKEN
PROPERTY TAX. AND SO I THINK-
BACK NEEDS TO BE UNDERSCORED
HERE. THANK YOU AND I HAVE ONE
LAST QUESTION WHICH I NORMALLY
GET ASKED BY MANY OF MY LOCAL
AGENCIES BUT ARE THERE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON HOW LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN USE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. GAGE AGAIN- NO THE
ANSWER IS THESE ARE- GENERAL
PURPOSE REVENUES- TO BE USED
FOR ANY LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENTAL
PURPOSE. SO LOCAL GOVERNMENT OF
ALL STRIPES HAVE DISCRETION AS
TO HOW THOSE MONIES ARE SPENT
GREAT. ANSWER THAT ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KILEY. THANK YOU ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HEAR FROM FOLKS
ABOUT THIS INITIATIVE IS THAT
IF IT PASSES THEN THE
PROTECTIONS FOR HOMEOWNERS WILL
BECOME A MORE VULNERABLE AND SO
I JUST WANTED TO GIVE EACH OF
THE PROPONENTS- AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE AN ASSURANCE THAT
YOUR- ULTIMATELY AND-
MAINTAINING THE PROTECTIONS.
FOR RESIDENCES AND YOU DON'T
YOU THIS INITIATIVE AS ONE
STEP. DOWN THAT ROAD. THIS IS
CAROLYN GRAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
RESPONSE DAD BECAUSE THAT IS OF
PARTICULAR INTEREST TO HOT-
SINCE MOST SMALL BUSINESSES-
ARE OPERATING FROM THEIR HOME.
AND THE ABSOLUTELY NOT
RESIDENTS IN OUR PROTECT AND BY
THE MEASURE EXPLICITLY. THIS IS
TIM GAUGE I CAN ECHO THAT AS
WELL- THAT PROPONENTS MEASURE
HAD NO INTENTION OF ATTEMPTING
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE AS
HAS BEEN ASSERTED BY THE
OPPONENTS TRYING TO EXTEND THIS
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM TO
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY THIS IS
CLEARLY EXCLUDED- IN THE
MEASURE AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
SO. THIS IS TOXIC CUTLER HI MY
I'M A NURSE AND I AM- I'M OFF A
HOMEOWNER SO I AM SOMEBODY WHO
BENEFIT FROM THE- THAT CAP ON
ON IN CREEPING UP PROPERTY TAX
SO- THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT THAT AND I FIND IT VERY
DISINGENUOUS THAT WHEN PEOPLE
TO GET THAT THIS IS RAISING TAX
BERMAN. FOR CALIFORNIANS- THE
EQUIVALENT OF SAYING THAT- THAT
THIS IS THE GRAND THAT MAKE IT
THEN BAD ON THE ECONOMY UP THE
UP. THE BILLIONAIRES WHO HAVE-
MADE SO MUCH MONEY THAT THEY'VE
ACTUALLY BENEFITED FROM THAT.
PANDEMIC. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY. THANK YOU JUST REAL
QUICKLY I USED TO SERVE ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD SO EDUCATION
FUNDING IS A MAJOR PRIORITY AND
IF I'M READING THE LA- ANALYSTS
CORRECTLY IT SAYS
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND FAMOUS
TO THE STATE COME THE FIRST
THANK ON PAYMENTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THEN LAST OUR
SCHOOLS AND I'M JUST WONDERING
WHY SCHOOLS ARE THE LOWEST
FUNDING PRIORITY IN THIS
MEASURE. I THINK IT'S A CLEAR
MISREADING A MEASURE TO THINK
THAT SCHOOLS ARE THE LOWEST
PRIORITY- THEY'RE NOT- THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY GOING TO
SCHOOLS IS SIMPLY A- BASED ON
THE CURRENT SHARES OF LOCAL
PROPERTY TAXES SO THAT SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY RECEIVING 40% OF.
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES NAY
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IN THE
FUTURE. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THING AND I'LL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO MY CULTURE. THANK YOU
AND NOW WE'RE ON TO THE
OPPONENTS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME UP AND I WILL GIVE
NAMES AND WE'LL INTRODUCE YOU
THROUGH THE MODERATOR. MR
JULIAN AT- AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE DR JON CALL MR DONE A
JOHN COULD FALL FROM PRESENT
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND MR LERI STONE
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
ASSESSOR. I CALIFORNIA'S
SISTERS ASSOCIATION YOU HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO SPLIT
BETWEEN THE THREE OF YOU-
PLEASE NOW CONNECT US TO THE
CAPITAL WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE. MR JULIAN CAN FIRST. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR. I'M NOT
A JAZZ BURKE I DON'T CARE-
CURRY IN MEMBERS DRINKING AT A
PRESIDENCY OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AT THIS JOINT HEARING
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF STATIC
ON BUSINESSES AND ALSO SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC CRISIS.
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS ARE
GROWING BY THE DAY. AND MAY
REACH LEVELS WE HAVEN'T SEEN
SINCE THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
TODAY HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT
BUSINESS AND BIG BUSINESS AND
OFTENTIMES IT SEEMS LIKE OUR
PROPONENTS TESTIMONY MAKES IT
SEEM LIKE THAT ANYONE WHO OWNS
A BUSINESS IS A MILLION OR
BILLION THERE. THAT COULD NOT
BE ANY FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH
EVEN THOUGH THE BEST OF TIMES.
I'M HERE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE FOUR
MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND A SEVEN POINT
ONE MILLION SMALL BUSINESS
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE HANGING ON BY
A THREAD. SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
STRUGGLING TO RE OPEN THEIR
DOORS AND STAY IN BUSINESS. AND
YET HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
RAISING PROPERTY TAXES ON
BUSINESSES BY AS MUCH AS TWELVE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. 48% OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE OUR IN OUR POINT MY
SMALL BUSINESS. AGAIN 48% OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE EMPLOYED
BY SMALL BUSINESS SEVEN POINT
ONE WORKERS IN ALL AND LET'S BE
CLEAR PROPONENTS MAY BELIEVE
THAT THEY HAVE TRAIN THEIR
SIGHTS ON THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BUT THE TAB CALLED
ONLY BE PAID BY BOTH SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ALL OF US
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS. YOU AND
I WILL PAY MORE FOR EVERYTHING
WE BUY AND USE FROM RESTAURANTS
IN HERE CUTS A GALLON OF MILK
AND EIGHT TO CLOSE DAY CARE
HEALTH CARE FUEL AND TELL THE
COST. SO THE PANDEMIC PANDEMIC
AGAIN. THIS BODY HAS DEBATED
MANY MEASURES TO PROVIDE RELIEF
TO SMALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING
RESTAURANTS RETAIL SHOP OWNERS
THROUGHOUT THIS GREAT STATE.
YET THE MEASURE WOULD HARM THIS
MEASURE WOULD HARM MANY OF THE
SAME BUSINESS AT A TIME WHEN
THEY ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
NUMEROUS STUDIES INCLUDING
THOSE BY THE END DOUBLE ACP OF
CALIFORNIA PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS UP TAXPAYER
FOUNDATION ALSO I THAT WOULD
PROPERTY TAXES INCREASED ON
BUSINESS PROPERTIES SMALL
BUSINESSES PAY MORE. MOST SMALL
BUSINESSES RENT THE PROPERTY
WHERE THEY OPERATE THE PLACE OF
BUSINESS AND MOST OF THE
RELEASES INCLUDE. WHAT IS
CALLED A TRIPLE NET LEASE THAT
MEANS BUSINESS RENTALS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROPERTY TAXES
INSURANCE AND MAINTENANCE COSTS
BY THE WAY ACCORDING THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES SEVENTY
EIGHT PERCENT. OF ALL SPACE
BUSINESSES NOT ON THE PROPERTY
THEY RANKED. SO THAT MEANS THE
MEASURES HIGHER PROPERTY TAXES
WILL TRANSLATE TO INCREASE
RENTS FOR THE MAJORITY OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AT A TIME WHEN THE
VERY SMALL. THE VERY SAME SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE JUST TRYING TO
KEEP THE DOORS OPEN AND THEIR
WORKERS EMPLOYED WHEN PROPERTY
TAXES AND LET THE PRIEST SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE LEFT WITH FEW
CHOICES. THEY CAN SHUT THE
DOORS ALREADY A REALITY IN
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING WOULD BE LOS. LAY
OFF EMPLOYEES THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
FACE IS HOW TO RE HIRE
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE LAID OFF IN
PANDEMIC. OR MOVE OUT OF STATE.
THAT THIS IS NOT LIKELY OPTION.
HOW CALIFORNIA. PRESENT SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WITH IS A
POSSIBLE CHOICE. NOTHING IN THE
SPLIT WILL MEASURE EXEMPTS
SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
REASSESSMENT. THE SPLIT WILL
MEASURES REASSESSMENT PROVISION
DOES NOT EVEN MENTION THE WORD
SMALL BUSINESS AT ALL. INSTEAD
IT HINGES REASSESSMENT ON THE
VALUE IN OWNERSHIP OF A
PROPERTY. THAT MEANS THE
MAJORITY OF SMALL BUSINESSES
WON'T QUALIFY FOR THE FULL
PERSONAL PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
OR THE TEMPORARY RELIEF. FROM
REASSESSMENT THAT REPORT. LET
ME TAKE. MASSIVE TAX INCREASE
WILL HURT SMALL BUSINESSES
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN. IF WORK IF YOU'RE
ALL SERIOUS. ABOUT RETURNING
CALIFORNIA TO ECONOMIC CAL
START WITH CALIFORNIA'S ONE
FOUR MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES.
A SMALL BUSINESSES FOR
SUPPORTING THE LARGEST PROPERTY
TAX INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY IS THE LAST THING THAT
OUR STATE NEEDS TO GET SMALL
BUSINESSES BACK ON THEIR FEET
AND SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
SMALL BUSINESS WORKERS BACK TO
THEIR JOBS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NOW WE'LL HAVE
OUR NEXT PRESENTER AND THAT
WILL BE OF A. JOHN COOPER
BREAUX PRESENT HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WELCOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU CO CHAIRS
BURKE AND I'VE WORKED CURRY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M
JUNK FALL PRESIDENT THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST TAXPAYER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION ARE OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
INITIATIVE FIRST. TAXPAYERS ARE
ALSO CONSUMERS TAXES ON
BUSINESSES HAVE AN INSIDIOUS
WAY OF TRICKLING DOWN TO
CONSUMERS IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
COSTS FOR GOODS AND SERVICES
CALIFORNIA'S COST OF LIVING IS
ALREADY WAY ABOVE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE AND WE DON'T NEED TO
ADD TO THAT BURDEN FOR MIDDLE
CLASS RESIDENTS. MUCH OF THE
COST OF LIVING CALIFORNIA'S
DRIVEN BY HIGH TAXES BUT EVEN
RESOLVE THE HEALTH ISSUES
CURRENTLY RELATED TO THE COAL
BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HIGHER
TAXES ARE THE LAST THING WE
NEED RIGHT NOW. THE STATE
ALREADY HAS THE HIGHEST INCOME
TAX RATE AMERICA THIRTEEN POINT
THREE PERCENT. WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST STATE SALES TAX RATE IN
AMERICA WE HAVE THE HIGHEST GAS
TAX IN AMERICA WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST CORPORATE TAX WHICH THE
MISSISSIPPI AND COMPETING
AGAINST OTHER STATES. WHICH
WITH- AND WE NOW WE CAN'T
REALLY COMPETE AGAINST THEM IN
TERMS OF BUSINESS CLIMATE. AND
WHEN THE COST OF LIVING IS
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT CALIFORNIA
HAS THE HIGHEST POVERTY RATE IN
THE NATION. MORE IMPORTANTLY
CALIFORNIA IS NOT EVEN A LOW
PROPERTY TAX STATE. CALIFORNIA
RANKS SEVENTEEN OTHER FIFTY IN
PER CAPITA PROPERTY TAX
COLLECTIONS SO THIS MYTH THAT
SOMEHOW PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
IT'S GOT A PROPERTY TAXES IN
CALIFORNIA IS SIMPLY NOT BORNE
OUT BY THE EVIDENCE. TAXPAYERS
ARE ALSO WORD BECAUSE THE
PROPONENTS HAVE OPENLY ADMITTED
THAT RAISING TAXES ON
BUSINESSES IS JUST THE FIRST
STEP IN THE COMPLETE
DISMANTLING OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN OUT. WHAT PROVIDE
BOATS ONE BECAUSE I KNOW JUST
GOT SOME PUSH FROM THE
PROPONENTS ON THAT POINT.
HOMEOWNERS ARE WELL JUSTIFIED
IN FEARING THAT THE LOSS OF
PROP THIRTEEN FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WILL BE FOLLOWED
QUICKLY BY PROPOSALS TO REMOVE
PROTECTIONS FOR INCOME
PRODUCING RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES THAT DEPARTMENTS AND
THEN AFTER THAT. OF OWNER
OCCUPIED SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
WE ARE ALSO VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HIGH COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS SOME
COUNTY IS A RURAL AREAS WHERE
MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS RESIDE
WILL ACTUALLY SEEN A LOSS IN
REVENUE. AND I WILL LEAVE IT TO
THE ASSESSOR OF SANTA CLARA
LAURIE STONE WHO'S HERE IN THE
ROOM TO ADDRESS THAT THE
MYRIAD. OF IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
INITIATIVE. LET ME SPEND A
MOMENT TO ADDRESS HOW THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD EXACERBATE. WELL
WELL WHAT DO YOU. IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST FISCAL
CHALLENGES I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY DISPUTES THAT WE ARE SO
OVERLY RELIANT ON A HANDFUL OF
WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS THAT AND
BOOM TIMES REVENUE JUST COMES
FLOWING IN THE DOOR BUT IN
RECESSIONARY TIMES THE DROP. IS
PARTICULARLY SEVERE INDEED
REVENUE VOLATILITY IS SUCH A
LARGE PROBLEM THE GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION FOR THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ECONOMY
ALSO KNOWS THE PARTS THE
COMMISSION TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS REGRETTABLY THERE WAS
BROAD CONSENSUS THAT REVENUE
VOLATILITY IS IN FACT ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST PROBLEMS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE COMMISSIONERS
COULD NOT COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION. BUT DURING THE
COMMISSION'S HEARING PROCESS
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S PRODUCE A
CHART SHOWING THE VOLATILITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S REV TAX REVENUES
THE CHART DEPICTED A GREAT DEAL
OF VOLATILITY IN INCOME TAXES.
NOT SO MUCH VOLATILITY IN SALES
TAXES BUT STILL PRONOUNCED AN
EXTRAORDINARY STABILITY IN THE
PROPERTY TAX FREE. INDEED IN
200-082-0009 WE HAD DECLINES IN
INCOME TAXES SALES TAXES. AND
THE CLIENTS IN THE MARKET VALUE
OF PROPERTY BUT INCREASES IN
PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS WHY.
ALL THE EQUITY WHICH IN THE
AGGREGATE COULD NOT BE TAX
BECAUSE THE 2% LIMITATION.
PROVIDED A HUGE CUSHION TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INDEED EVEN
ONE MARKET VALUES OF PROPERTY
WERE DECLINING RAPIDLY MANY
COUNTIES CONTINUE TO SEE YEAR
OVER YEAR INCREASES IN REVENUE.
THIS INITIATIVE MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT. WILL TAKE
CALIFORNIA'S PROBLEM REVENUE
VOLATILITY. REVENUE VOLATILITY
CAN MAKE IT MUCH MUCH WORSE.
A MOMENT- DISPEL IN TWO MINUTES
THIS MEMORY ONLY HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR ALL SPEAKERS THANK
YOU RIGHT. OF FIRST IS THE
OFTEN HEARD WITH FALSE ARGUMENT
TO PROP THIRTEEN COST REDUCTION
OF PER PUPIL SPENDING IN
EDUCATION. THE REALITY IS THE
CALIFORNIA DAY OF SPENDING 30%
MORE ON A PER STUDENT PLACE TO
ADJUSTED BASIS THEN WE WORDS
PRIOR TO THE ADOPTION OF
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN A TIME
WHEN THERE WAS. THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION WAS TOP NOTCH- A
SECOND MYTH IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THAT PROP THIRTEEN
SOMEHOW. THIS IS THERE'S NOT
TRUE TELEPHONE HAS A HAD A UNIT
ROLE OF. UNIFIED TO ROLL SO THE
EIGHTEEN FIFTIES PROP THIRTEEN
AND NOT CHANGE THAT. AND THE
OTHER ARGUMENT WE HEAR IS THAT
VOTERS WERE NOT BORN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE
BUSINESS PROPERTIES WERE
PROTECTED THAT'S PATENTLY FALSE
THAT ARGUMENT WAS IN THE BALLOT
ARGUMENT. NO FINALLY THAT THE
PP I SEE POLL THAT JUST CAME
OUT SHOW THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE A DEAD
SET AGAINST NEW TAXES BY TWO TO
ONE MARGIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE HAVE
MR LERI STONE I KNOW WE'RE ON
LIMITED TIME HERE BUT- IF YOU
PLEASE LIKE TO START. YES A
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LARRY STONE
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY ASSESSOR
I SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING ALL
FIFTY EIGHT ASSESSORS.
ASSESSORS BY CONSTITUTION ARE
INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED AND HAVE
A RANGE OF POLITICAL OPINIONS
AS DIVERSE AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT UNITES US
HOWEVER IS OUR STEADFAST
COMMITMENT FOR OUR PROFESSIONAL
INTEGRITY AS PROPERTY TAX
ADMINISTRATORS. MY COMMENTS
WILL ONLY ADDRESS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OPERATIONAL
ISSUES WITH THE SPLIT ROLE
BALLOT INITIATIVE. THE
CALIFORNIA- OF. CALIFORNIA
SISTERS ASSOCIATION HAS
COMPLETED A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF THE SPLIT ROLE
BALLOT MEASURE WITH ONLY ONE
QUESTION IN MIND CAN ASSESSORS
IMPLEMENT THE INITIATIVE OUR
CONCLUSION IS WE CANNOT. IT
WOULD E IMPOSSIBLE NOT
DIFFICULT BUT IMPOSSIBLE TO
ADMINISTER ALL OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE MEASURE AS IT
IS WRITTEN. LAST WEEK THE
CALIFORNIA SUCH AS ASSOCIATION
VOTED TO FORMALLY OPPOSE THE
SPLIT LAUREL INITIATING. THE
BIG PROBLEM FOR ASSESSORS AS
MANY IS THE MANY EXCLUSIONS. A
REASSESSMENT IN THE INITIATIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE IF IT EXCLUDES
REASSESSMENT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES SOUNDS GOOD. WELL
MOST SMALL BUSINESSES DON'T OWN
PROPERTY THEY PAY THE PROPERTY
TAXES THROUGH THEIR LEAKS SO
MOST ALL SMALL BUSINESS TENANTS
WOULD NOT GET THE BENEFIT OF
THE EXCLUSION. THE SPLIT ROLE
EXCLUDES OWNER OCCUPIED
PROPERTY IN WHICH THE FAIR
MARKET VALUE IS LESS THAN THREE
MILLION STATE WHY. FIRST A SET
ONLY KNOW THE FAIR MARKET VALUE
OF THE PROPERTY. QUITE AT THE
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP OR NEW
CONSTRUCTION AFTER THAT WE ONLY
TRACK ASSESSED BALLOT.
ASSESSORS CANNOT DETERMINE THE
AGGREGATE- MARKET VALUE OF
MULTIPLE PROPERTIES IN MULTIPLE
COUNTS. THERE'S ALSO A RELATED
PROBLEM THE THREE MILLION CAP
THE THREE MILLION DOLLAR CAP IS
ADJUSTED BY ANNUALLY BY COUNTY
BASED UPON A LOCAL INFLATION
FACTOR DETERMINED BY THE STATE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. THE
RESULT IS OVER TIME DIFFERENT
INFLATION FACTORS IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES SO YOU CAN HAVE
IDENTICAL PROPERTY SAID TWO
IDENTICAL TACO BELLS IN
ADJACENT COUNTIES OFTEN THREE
OR FOUR MILES APART WITH
DIFFERENT INFLATION FACTOR. THE
RESULT EXACT PROPERTIES WILL
EXPERIENCE DIFFERENT ASSESSED
VALUES OVER TIME. FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS ASSESSORS HAVE DONE
A DEEP DIVE INTO THE FINANCIAL
pSPLIT ROLE. FIRST WE SURVEYED
ASSESSORS REGARDING THE IMPACT
THE SPLIT ROLE WOULD HAVE ON
STAFFING AND WORK LOOK. THEN WE
COMMISSION TO NONPARTISAN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS I CAPITAL
MATRIX WHICH CONCLUDED THAT ARE
ESTIMATES WERE WAY LOW. AND
THAT THE ESTIMATED COST TO
IMPLEMENT THE INITIATIVE OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PROPOSED
THREE YEAR PHASE IN. IS JUST
OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS STATE
WHY AND THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE COMMENSURATE INCREASE IN
COST. FOR COUNTY CONTROLLERS
TAX COLLECTORS ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARDS OR COUNTY
COUNCIL. THE BALLOT MEASURE
REQUIRES AS WE KNOW THE
REASSESSMENT OF ALL COMMERCIAL.
PROPERTIES TO MARKET VALUE
EVERY THREE YEARS. WHAT HAPPENS
AT THE GREAT RECESSION OR A
PANDEMIC OCCURS IN YOUR NUMBER
TWO. AND THE PROPERTY VALUES
DROPPED BY 50% AS THEY DID
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
REQUIRING ANNUAL REVIEW OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY ELIMINATING
THE BENEFIT OF SPREADING THE
REASSESSMENTS OVER THREE YEARS.
ASSESSMENT APPEALS WOULD
SKYROCKET. AT THE VERY LEAST
EVERY COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNED
PRIOR TO SAY TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT PICK YOUR DATE WOULD
APPEAL. WHY NOT MUCH TO BE
GAINED WITH LOW RICK'S. SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WE RECEIVE TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED AMERICAN COMMERCIAL
APPEALS LAST YEAR THAT'S FAIRLY
NORMAL. CONSERVATIVELY WE
PROJECT THAT WE WOULD RECEIVE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND APPEALS IN
THE FIRST YEAR. IT WOULD BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY TO RESOLVE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND COMMERCIAL APPEAL WHEN
WE WILL BE. ASSESSORS WOULD
TRANSFER APPRAISAL RESOURCES
FROM ENROLLING NEW CONSTRUCTION
AND CHANGES OF OWNERSHIP. WHERE
THE REAL REVENUE IS TO
DEFENDING APPEALS JEOPARDIZING
CURRENT CROP PROPERTY TAXES.
THE SPLIT ROLL INITIATIVE.
WOULD WOULD WOULD BE AN
INVITATION TO ADJUDICATE
APPEALS IN COURT RATHER THAN
THE THAN BEFORE THE LOCAL
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD
CREATING A MONUMENTAL INCREASE
IN THE COST OF RESOLVING APPEAL.
IT TAKES ME FIVE YEARS TO TAKE
AN ENTRY LEVEL APPRAISER AND
PUT THAT APPRAISER IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY CAN WHERE
THEY CAN APPRAISE IT CAN ASSESS.
SHOPPING CENTERS ON OFF
BUILDINGS THE BALLOT MEASURE
GIVES IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS. YOU
KNOW. IT'S REALLY. WELL LET ME
CONCLUDE BY BY SAYING THIS
WHENEVER GOVERNMENT PROMISES
SOMETHING THAT CAN'T BE A CHEAT
IT JUST INCREASES THE MISTRUST
AND CYNICISM THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS TOWARD THE GOVERNMENT
ELECTED OFFICIALS THIS IS A
SERIOUSLY FLAWED BALLOT MEASURE
IN IT SHOULD BE DEFEATED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MEMBERS DO ANY OF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE DRAWING GO FIRST I
HAVE ACTUALLY THREE QUESTIONS
MY FIRST QUESTIONS FOR THE LA
L. ONE OF THE OPPONENTS BROUGHT
UP THE FACT THAT THE TRIPLE NET
LEASES WILL HAVE AFFECTS ON
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MY
QUESTION WOULD BE HAS YOUR
ANALYSIS TAKEN THAT INTO- INTO
CONSIDERATION WHICH I KNOW YOU
DID MENTION IT DOES BUT HOW.
AND THEN ALSO DO YOU HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT THAT
RELIEF WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES IF IN FACT-
THAT TRIPLE NET LEASE OBVIOUSLY
WOULD INCREASE THE COST TO
SMALL BUSINESS. YES THANK YOU
SO THE PRIMARY CHARGE OF OUR-
ANALYSIS IS TO LOOK AT THE
MEASURES FISCAL FAX- ECONOMIC
EFFECTS OF THE MEASURE- CAN
PLAY INTO- THE ESTIMATES OF THE
PHYSICAL BUT THEY ARE KIND OF
THE- THE PRIMARY- ANALYSIS FOR
A MEASURE SO. QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW KIND OF ECONOMIC POLICY
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THIS MIGHT
AFFECT SMALL BUSINESSES WERE
WERE NOT REALLY WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF ESTIMATING THE
PROPERTY TAX AFFECTS FROM THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU I MEAN WOULD
YOU A TEST THAT. POTENTIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASE OF THAT
TRAFFIC TROUBLE NEED NOT LEASE
COSTS THAT SMALL BUSINESS WOULD
BE AFFECTED. ALTHOUGH THE PROP
UP OTHER THE PROPOSITION WAS
WRITTEN TO TRY NOT TO THINK
SMALL BUSINESS OR WOULD BE
STILL AND AFFECT ON SMALL
BUSINESS. I THINK I WOULD SAY
THAT- IT'S CERTAINLY POSSIBLE
THAT THERE COULD BE BUSINESSES
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED SMALL
BUSINESS- THAT COULD BE A
RENTING THEIR SPACE- IN A
BUILDING. THAT WOULD NOT BE
EXEMPT UNDER THIS THIS MEASURE
FROM THE SHIFT TO A MARKET
VALUE TAXATION- AND- DESPITE
TEN GAUGES. I THINK FAIRLY A
REASONABLE REMARKS ABOUT A
COMMERCIAL RENTS BEING SET BY
LARGELY BY KIND OF MOVE THE
MARKET RATES THERE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE SOME SITUATIONS
WHERE. LANDLORDS FACING
PROPERTY TAX INCREASES COULD
SEEK TO RENEGOTIATE LEASES OVER
TIME OKAY THANK YOU. ARE MY
NEXT QUESTION IS TO THE
OPPONENTS SOME PEOPLE CONTEND
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM AND
EQUITABLY FAVORS LONGSTANDING
BUSINESSES OVER NEWER
BUSINESSES BY A CREATING A
PERPETUAL COME AT PERPETUAL
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE-
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE PROPERTIES
ARE SOLD IN THE PAST AND THE
WAY THAT PROPERTIES ARE SOLD-
IN THEIR DEALS COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT CRITICISM. NOT
THE ONLY OF THE OPPONENTS. WELL
THERE YEAH BECAUSE THE PROPERTY
TAX SYSTEM IS SO DIVERSE
DEPENDING ON HOW LONG YOU'VE
OWNED YOUR PROPERTY IF YOU'RE A
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNER-
THERE IS TREMENDOUS DISPARITY.
IN HIS SO WHEN YOU TRY TO Q.
OR- THOSE DISPARITIES WITH ONE
BALLOT MANAGER AT ONE TIME IT
CREATES IT WILL CREATE
TREMENDOUS DESTRUCTION IN THE
SYSTEM. LBC WINNERS THEY'LL BE
LOSERS- AND- I MEAN THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY I CAN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I THINK. I THINK- AND
THEN FOR THE PROPONENTS CAN YOU
ADDRESS THE ASSESSORS CONCERN
ON ACTUALLY DOING DOING ACTUAL
LEGWORK OF THE PROPOSITION.
THIS IS TIM GAUGE I'D BE HAPPY
TO ADDRESS THAT- WE SPENT-
NUMEROUS HOURS IN CONVERSATION
WITH THE- ASSESSORS- OVER THE
LAST PERIOD OF THREE TO FOUR
YEARS IN AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS- AND PART OF
WHAT'S INCLUDED IN- THIS
MEASURE IS A RE WRITE OF A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS. TO DEAL
WITH- SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS SO
FOR EXAMPLE- THE CONCERN THAT
THE SISTERS WOULD NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT TIME IN ORDER TO
TRAIN STAFF. AND GET UP TO
SPEED- THE MEASURE IS
EXPLICITLY WRITTEN TO PROVIDE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
CONVENE A TASK FORCE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. LOOKING AT WHAT
WOULD BE INVOLVED IN
IMPLEMENTATION AND THEIR- THE
ASSESSORS ARE CALLED OUT
SPECIFICALLY TO BE A MEMBER
THAT TASK FORCE AND THE
LEGISLATURE- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
STAND- PHASE IN PERIOD- SO IN
THE MEASURE RIGHT NOW IT'S A
MINIMUM OF THREE YEARS.
STARTING WITH- TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- THE
MEASURE SPECIFIES THAT THERE
HAS TO BE AT LEAST A THREE YEAR
PHASE IN PERIOD BUT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE COULD EXTEND THAT.
BASED ON DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ASSESSORS- SECOND- THE CONCERNS
RAISED ABOUT COST- TWO COMMENTS
ONE IS I THINK MR STUFF. LA THE
US OF COP WE HAVE NOT LOOKED
SPECIFICALLY- OR MADE AN
ESTIMATE SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE
START UP COSTS-WOULD BE BUT WE
DID LOOK AT THE QUESTION OF
WHAT THE ON GOING COSTS WOULD
BE IN OUR BEST SENSE IS THAT
THEY WOULD BE LESS THAN A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. ONCE THE MEASURES THAT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE- START UP
COSTS WHOEVER HAS THE MEASURE
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THE
MEASURE SPECIFIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. IS TO PROVIDE A
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION FOR
THE START COSTS WHICH WOULD
THEN BE PAID BACK FROM THE
REVENUES GENERATED BY THE
MEASURE ITSELF SO. THAT THE-
RELATE TO OR THE CONCERN
RELATED TO START UP COSTS- SIX
THREE ONE WITHOUT A- FOUNDATION
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THOSE START
UP COSTS ARE ALL COVERED BY THE
REVENUES GENERATED BY THE
MEASURE. AND THEN LASTLY WITH
RESPECT TO- ASSESSMENT APPEALS-
MR STONE- ARGUED THAT THE-
NUMBER OF ASSESSMENT APPEALS
WOULD DRAMATICALLY INCREASE- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT CONCERN WE MADE
CHANGES. IN THE MEASURE TO THE
WAY IN WHICH THE ASSESSMENT
APPEALS PROCESS WOULD BE
HANDLED- SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. TRYING TO REDUCE
THE- NUMBER OF APPEALS WOULD BE
BROUGHT FORWARD. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN. OF THANK
YOU RESPECTIVE OF MADAME SHARES
MY QUESTION IS FOR ASSESSOR
STONE AND I DON'T KNOW BRIAN
HAS ANYTHING TO ADD ON THIS BUT
AT IN THE REPORTS SPLIT ROLE
IMPLEMENTATION ESTIMATE ACOSTA
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S THERE'S
REFERENCE TO THE MEASURE
ALLOWING COUNTIES TO WITHHOLD
SOME PORTION OF ANY NET
ADDITIONAL REVENUES RESULTING
FROM THE MEASURE TO COVER THEIR
COSTS OF IMPLEMENTATION. AND I
APOLOGIZE IF THIS IS BEEN ****
A DIFFICULT TO CATCH ALL THE
AUDIO HERE- BUT ASSESSOR STONE
ARE YOU. SUGGESTING THAT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH LIKE
FLEXIBILITY WITH WITH THAT
MECHANISM TO RECOUP THE COSTS
IN TERMS OF- REIMBURSEMENTS TO
THE ASSESSORS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION. WE WOULD HAVE
TO ASSESSORS WOULD HAVE TO
FRONT COST IF YOU WILL- THE
START UP. IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
FOR THE MEASURE THAT SAYS WE
WOULD BE REIMBURSED. WELL LET
ME JUST GIVE AND HE'S- GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR EXCLUSION OF
THE ASSESSMENT OF BUSINESS
PROPERTY. WOULD IN SOME SMALL
CAN. EXCEED THE ANTICIPATED
REVENUES FROM THE SPLIT ROLE IN
OTHER WORDS A PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE REDUCTION. WHAT HAPPENS
ALL IT IS THAT THAT. THAT SO
WHEN THAT HAPPENS THOSE SMALL
COUNTIES WOULD BE VERY RETICENT
ABOUT YEAH FRONT MONEY VIA THE
START UP COSTS WHEN THEY COULD
GET THEY HAD NO EXPECTATION
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE ANY
REVENUE COMING FROM THE SPLIT
ROLE MEASURE ITSELF. SO THIS
WHOLE IDEA PARTICULARLY IN THE
IN THE ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE RIGHT NOW
WHERE BUDGET CUTS IN STAFF CUTS
ALL ACROSS THE STREET OR OR
CURRENT. TO BE EXPECT. COUNTY
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS IN
PARTICULAR- TO FRONT COST.
SIGNIFICANT COST TO START. THIS
PROCESS IN THE EXPECTATION THAT
YOU MAKE MAY BE IN FOR FIVE
YEARS BE REIMBURSED FOR THOSE
COSTS IT'S LIKELY THAT MOST
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS ARE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT. I APPRECIATE
THAT ASSESSOR STONE IN TERMS OF
ESPECIALLY SMALLER COUNTIES AND
FRONTING MONEY AND SOME OF THE
DIFFICULTIES THERE BUT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE MEASURE THAT
WOULD PREVENT. ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES FROM FROM BEING MADE
WHOLE IN TERMS OF THE COST OF
THE ACTUAL. ADMINISTRATION OF
THIS THIS NEW BURGER CORRECT I
MEAN THIS THIS. THERE'S A
FLEXIBILITY THERE TO RECOUP
THOSE COSTS OVER TIME I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT UP FRONT
CONCERNED HOWEVER BRICK BUT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WOULD
PREVENT YOU FROM RECOUPING ALL
OF THOSE COSTS OVER TIME
CORRECT. IF YOU ASSUME THAT THE
REVENUE IS GOING TO COME IN AS
I SAID I BELIEVE IN THE
ASSESSORS BELIEVE. THAT THAT
THAT THE PROJECTIONS ON SIX TO
ELEVEN AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF REVENUE IS NOT
GOING TO BE. ANYWHERE NEAR THAT
AT THE END OF THE DAY AND THE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS OF THE
CHEATING THAT- THERE'S I THINK.
COUNTIES WOULD BE RESIDENT
ABOUT THAT THE MEASURE PROVIDES
THAT EXCEPT WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. OKAY
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT. MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS TEN GAUGE I WONDER IF I
CAN ADDRESS- MISTER STONES- ONE
OF MR STONE'S COMMENT. YES. THE
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THE
MEASURE SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
START UP COSTS SO I GUESS I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE SENSORS NEEDING TO.
HEY FOR THOSE COSTS UP FRONT
GIVEN THAT PROVISION WHICH IS
NOT. SIMPLY AN AUTHORIZATION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DO SO
BUT IS MANDATORY. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS- I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO ASK. AS
WE KNOW CALIFORNIA IS IN DIRE
NEED OF AN INCREASE IN SCHOOL
FUNDING INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THE CRITICISMS THAT MANY
BUSINESSES ARE NOT PAYING THEIR
FAIR SHARE. ANYONE IF YOU COULD
ANSWER. CHARLIE GRAY HERE I
REALLY LIKE TO RESPOND YEAH
PLEASE AND I THINK IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION ACT WE
CONSIDER THE FUTURE WE KNOW
THAT THAT WE OPENING OUR
SCHOOLS WILL BE ACT IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT THAT. MAIN STREET
CALIFORNIA EDUCATE THERE WERE
NINE POINT CHOOSE ONLY IN A
PRESCHOOL THREE UNIVERSITY
WHICH IS INVOLVED AT THE PRE
SCHOOL ELEMENTARY OR SECONDARY
SCHOOL LEVEL WE KNOW THAT FOR
OUR BUSINESSES FIVE HAVE WORKED.
AFTER PREPARED HIGHLY. AND
DIVERSE. BACK HOME WITH
POSSIBLE WITH SCHOOL BETTER
EQUIPPED TO EDUCATE PREPARE
CHILDREN TO BE THAT WORK FOR
YOU IF YOU GOT WHAT. SCOLDED
FOR OFF. SURE HAS CHEN GARNERED
ONE PLACE SEVEN MILLION
SIGNATURE I THE FORT AND IT
WOULD READ AN TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS EVERY OUR LOCAL. TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT AND IN FACT AND
CRITICAL LOCAL SERVICES THAT WE
ALL RELY ON. JOE THIS IS JOHN
PAUL THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU FOR HER. YEAH I'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT I THINK THE IG.
A RELEASE FROM CEO MAGAZINE
THIS WEEK A REVIEW BELIEVE FOR
THE FOURTEENTH TIME IN A ROW
FORTY YEARS IN A ROW CALIFORNIA
WAS RAIDED DEVIL LAST AS A
PLACE IN WHICH TO DO BUSINESS
THE BUSINESS CLIMATE HERE. IS
NOT VERY POSITIVE ALL OF US IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND SENATE DISTRICT
KNOWS BUSINESSES WITH OUR
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE MOVED OUT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
SOME OF THEM VERY VERY LARGE
BUSINESSES- SOME OF THEM SMALL
BUSINESSES. BUT WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT PROTECTING
OUR UP BUSINESS BASE BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO WILL BE
PAYING THE TAXES- GOING. AND
THE NOTION THAT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN SAYING IN A
SMALLER SHARE. OF THE PROPERTY
TAX BY THE WHOLE PROPERTY TAX
PROBABLY I WANT TO PUSH BACK
WILL GET. BACK AGAINST A TEN
GAUGE A LITTLE BIT. THAT IS
DRIVEN IN LARGE PART BY LAND
KEEPS KEEP IN MIND SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA BOSS. THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY THE DEFENSE INDUSTRY
OUR INDUSTRIAL BASE HAS SHRUNK.
SO THE PROPORTION. OF PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE RELATIVE BETWEEN
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL IS
REALLY AN AN IRRELEVANT. FIGURE
BECAUSE IS DRIVEN MORE BY LAND
USE POLICIES NOT TAX POLICY.
ANY OTHER COMMENT TO MY
QUESTION. BETTER THIS TIME GATE
YOU YOU HAD- ASKED FOR COMMENT
WITH RESPECT TO-
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HASN'T BEEN
DISCUSSED THIS MUCH MUCH THUS
FAR. IN TODAY'S- HEARING IS THE
FACT THAT BECAUSE THE
REASSESSMENT OF COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY WOULD RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE AND THE
PROPERTY TAX BASE THAT TAKES
TAX BASED NOT ONLY HAS THE ONE
PERCENT- TAX APPLIED TO IT BUT
ALSO THE- VOTER OVERRIDE RATE.
AS A CONSEQUENCE- THIS WOULD
INCREASE THE FISCAL CAPACITY
THE STATE TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIAL FASHION- AYE
MITCHELL LITTLE EARLIER MY
REMARKS THAT THEN SCHOOLS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE IN A
POSITION. TO PROVIDE MORE IN
THE WAY OF INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTICULARLY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WHERE- MANY OF
THOSE FACILITIES HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED. OKAY I HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUESTIONS AND ONE HANDED
OFF TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUNE.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
INITIATIVE SPECIFICALLY EXEMPTS
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY IS
INVOLVED SAID YET OPPONENTS
MATERIALS AND WEBSITES HAVE
CALL THIS INITIATIVE AND ATTACK
ON HOMEOWNERS. WOULD YOU CALL
THAT STATEMENT CORRECT AND
ACCURATE. OF THIS IS THE THIS
DRUG POLICY YES I THINK AGAIN
WE HAVE PUBLIC STATEMENTS
WHICH- WE CAN CERTAINLY MAKE
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE FROM
PROPONENTS ARE INTEREST SOCIO
THE PERFORMANCE- COMING OUT AND
SAYING QUITE CLEARLY THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP IF ANYBODY
BELIEVES. THE LAWSUIT
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN FOR
BUSINESS PROPERTIES IS SIMPLY
THE FIRST STEP I THINK I THINK
THERE'D BE FLOWN SO. I THINK
THERE IS A CLEAR AGENDA HERE
TO- DISMANTLE ALL THE PROJECT
PROPOSITION THIRTY. FOR THE
EFFORT THE NFIB REPORTS OF MOST
SMALL BUSINESSES OPERATE FROM
THEIR HOME SO WHAT THE SAME
SMALL BUSINESSES BE EXAM. UNDER
THE MEASURE THEY WOULD BE YES
MADAM CHAIRMAN. ANY OTHER
COMMENT. I GUESS THE QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE IS IT FOR A HOME
BASED BUSINESS- WHAT IS THE
PENALTY FOR NOT SECURING YOUR
BUSINESS LICENSE AND- IN IN OUR
IT AS THERE IS A SHIFT TOWARD
HOME BASED BUSINESSES ARE
THEY'RE GONNA BE ZONING
RESTRICTIONS AND ARE THEY GOING
TO BE ENFORCEMENT OF. GENERAL
PLANNING AND ZONING LAWS WITH
RESPECT TO OPERATING A BUSINESS
OUT OF YOUR HOME THERE SO. I
THINK THAT'S ONE THING THE HOME
BASED BUSINESSES DO FEAR AND
THAT IS OF THE FACT THAT- SOME
OF THE ENFORCEMENT DISEASE WILL
BE LOOKING TO SEE. WHO HAS A
BUSINESS LICENSE AND WHAT WHAT
HAVE THEY IDENTIFIED AS THEIR
ADDRESS AND WHETHER OR NOT
OPERATING A BUSINESS IS
CONSISTENT. WITH THE LAND USE
POLICIES OF THAT CITY SO I
THINK THAT'S A CONCERN THAT
WOULD ALL HAVE TO LOOK. LOOK AT
GOING FORWARD. IN MY LAST SURE
I NAY YES IT IF I NAY CAROLING
GREAT HERE. I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON THAT THE RICH
THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN. THAT
78% OF THE REVENUE HERE WE'LL
COME FROM IT 6% OF THE MOST
VALUABLE. COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTY IN THE
STATE. AND I THINK THAT IT IS
NOT AN ACCIDENT THAT THE
WEALTHIER. AND COUNTIES ARE I'M
PUSHING BACK ON THERE IF THE-
IF THEY WOULD HAVE TO IS BACK
UP. SHARE WE NEED TO INCLUDE
CLOSE IN THE MEDIAN IN WE NEED
THE- REASON WHY BUSINESSES. OUT
OF THEIR HOME THEY SPEAK.
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY THAT VERY
RATE THAT BY THE MARKET NOT BY
THE PROPERTY TAX. AND WE DO NOT
LEAVE THE HOLDERS THAT THE
PROPERTY PASSING PROPERTY TAX
BEIJING ON THE TOPIC THAT THEY
DON'T DO THAT WE NEED AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND THEY'RE.
FUNDING ALLOW THAT. YOU'VE
MADAM CHAIR OF THIS IS LARRY
STONE AGAIN MAY I COMMENT ON
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT CAME
GAUGE THEY. THE ART REGARDING
THE COSTS AND WHETHER THEY'RE
BEING REIMBURSED OR NOT. UP THE
BIGGEST COST IN ANY ASSESSOR'S
OFFICES PERSONNEL. MY OFFICE
IT'S OVER 90% I WOULD HAVE TO
DOUBLE MY APPRAISAL STAFF. ALL
THAT MEANS IN MY COUNTY FIFTY
NEW SENIOR APPRAISERS
EXPERIENCED IN LA COUNTY IT'S
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NEW
APPRAISER AND WOULD HAVE TO
BEGIN THAT PROCESS BECAUSE IT
TAKES FIVE YEARS TO TAKE A- IT
LEVEL PREVIEW. THEY CAN DO HIGH
LEVEL COMMERCIAL ASSESSMENTS
AND APPRAISALS. ARE WE WOULD
NEED THAT FUNDING RIGHT NOW AND
I DON'T THINK THE MEASURE
PROVIDES FOR THOSE KINDS OF
INCREASED COSTS NOT ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE ASSESSORS BUT
BUT FOR. THE TAX COLLECTOR THE
CONTROLLER- THE COUNTY COUNCILS
OF. YEAH WE WOULD HAVE TO BEGIN
TO MAKE THOSE EXPENDITURES IN
TRAINING EXPENDITURES UP VERY
VERY QUICKLY THANK. SOUNDS LIKE
A JOB OPPORTUNITY. OKAY MY
FINAL QUESTION IS AND AS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MANY OF YOU
KNOW THAT I'M A BIG PROPONENT
OF INTERNET FOR ALL AND THAT'S
AN INFRASTRUCTURE SO. AS I
STATED THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EVEN BEFORE THE
BUDGET CRISIS WERE THE DIRE
NEED OF INCREASED INVESTMENTS
IN PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
SCHOOLS BROADBAND FOR RURAL
AREAS PUBLIC SAFETY FACILITIES
AND THE LIKE. YOU OPPOSE THIS
AN INITIATIVE BUT HOWARD JARVIS
THE CHAMBER AND WAS STATEWIDE
BUSINESS. THE INITIATIVE ONLY
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PRESENT AN INITIATIVE TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND A LOWER 55%
RATHER THAN A TWO THIRDS
SUPERMAJORITY. YOU OPPOSE IT
EVEN AFTER WE ADDED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AUDITS AND EXPENDITURE
PLAN CITIZENS COMMISSION AND A
PROVISION PREVENTING A BUSINESS
ONLY TAX AT THE REQUEST OF THE
STATE CHAMBER. IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD EVER
SUPPORT. YES IT'S JUST THAT
THIS JOB ALL OF THE YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED THAT- WE
HAVE A PERIODIC REVIEW TAX
CREDITS AND THINGS CALL TAX
EXPENDITURES AND UP WE WOULDN'T
DENY THAT PERHAPS OF OVERALL
REVIEW. SO CALLED TAX
EXPENDITURES WHICH SOME PEOPLE
CALLED LOOPHOLES MAY BE
APPROPRIATE IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT ONLY IF
COUPLED WITH A TOP TO BOTTOM
REVIEW OF HOW WE SPEND MONEY
CALIFORNIA HAS PERHAPS THE-
MOST. SAMPLE OF AN
INTERNATIONAL BLOOM DAHLE THE
MOTORS HIGH SPEED RAIL AND WHY
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THEIR PROJECT WASTING
PROBABLY A MILLION DOLLARS A
DAY ON A PROJECT THAT MOST
INTERNATIONAL TRANSPORTATION
EXPERTS. AND WILL NOT EVER BE
COMPLETED SO OF. THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT WE
WOULD SUPPORT A TOP TO BOTTOM
REVIEW OF PERFORMANCE REVIEWS
OF ALL GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AND
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
OPERATE MORE LIKE THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE
THAT NORMALLY DOES FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT BUT ALSO PERFORMED. I
THINK THAT'S LONG OVERDUE HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD YOU NOT AGREE THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A BALANCED BUDGET
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. YES THEY ARE THEY
HAVE TO HAVE BALANCED BUDGETS
BUT I WOULD PUSH BACK ON THE
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE MUCH OF
THE- COST DRIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- HAS TO DO
WITH THE- A CONTRACTS THEY THEY
FIND WITH THE- PUBLIC SECTOR.
EMPLOYMENT EUROPEANS AND MOST
OF THOSE NEGOTIATIONS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS WE ARE BIXEL. OF
WHAT ARE CALLED HE COIN
INITIATIVE WE- YEAH. LABOR BUT
THE VOTERS. WELL I JUST WANT A
REMINDER THE INITIATIVE THAT WE
TRIED TO GET THROUGH IS JUST
JUST TO ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PRESENT AN INITIATIVE WE
DIDN'T A LOT OF A- WE JUST ASK
THEM THAT. SO WITH THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ELSE HAVE A
COMMENT TO MY COMMENT. ALL
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JUST VERY QUICKLY- ALL I.
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
INITIATIVE JUST BECAUSE HE
REALLY EXCLUDE THAT THE
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY I WILL NOT SUPPORT.
A CHAIN ANY CHANGES TO THE- THE
PER DAY- A RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
AND I DON'T THINK THE VOTERS
WAS THEIR- I THINK THE-
INITIATIVE. ACTUALLY ASKING
DOES BUSINESS LARGE OR SMALL TO
REALLY DO MORE TO CONTRIBUTE.
TO THEIR LOCAL GOOD DAY LOCAL
COMMUNITY WE'RE THEIR EMPLOYEE
AND THEIR FAMILY CALL HOME SO.
THANK YOU. THING NO MORE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I WILL
BEGIN BY RECOGNIZING FIVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE GALLEY WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS INITIATIVE FOR UP TO ONE
MINUTE EACH. I WOULD NOW ASK
HER ON A- SO NO. OKAY I DO NOT
SEE ANY ONE IN THE GALLEY FOR
SUPPORT SO NOW. FOR YEAH IN
SUPPORT OKAY YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR EACH ONE OF YOU UP
TO FIVE PEOPLE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WOMEN- TERRY BRENNAN
BEHALF MESS YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT WE
REPRESENT THEIR SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND TAXPAYERS IN
CALIFORNIA- INCLUDING THE-
PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO WORK IN
MISTER STONE'S OFFICE IN.
SEVERAL ASSESSOR'S OFFICE AND-
WE ARE DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS INITIATIVE I'M A LITTLE
TROUBLED BY THE SS PROPOSITION.
MOST OF THE PROBLEMS MR STONE
ADDRESS OUR PROBLEMS INHERENT
IN THE ASSESSMENT PROGRAM NOT
CREATE BY THIS ADMISSION.
THEY'RE FULLY FUNDED BY THE
INITIATIVE THE MONEY'S THERE
LET'S GET TO WORK AND DO OUR
JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE. HI
I'M CAROL GOLDBERG CAROL MOON
GOLDBERG I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS INITIATIVE AS
IS OUR ORGANIZATION. WE
CERTAINLY HAVE COME TO
UNDERSTAND IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS. HOW MUCH CALIFORNIANS
NEED AND RELY ON THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SCHOOLS IN
PARTICULAR RECENTLY WE'VE SEEN
GREAT NEEDS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
FOR SERVICES TO OUR SENIOR AND
TO OUR CHILDREN TO NEEDS FOR
THINGS INFRASTRUCTURE BROADBAND
ACCESS SO THAT ARE KIDS CAN
LEARN OFF LINE- OR ONLINE
INSTEAD OF BEING IN SCHOOLS.
THIS INITIATIVE PUT MONEY
REVENUE TO FLEE INTO THE HANDS
OF THE DECISION MAKERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT THEY CAN
DETERMINE AND USE THIS MONEY.
FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL PROBLEMS
IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES
AT THE SAME TIME IT PROVIDES
FOR TRANSPARENCY AND I'LL
SEXUALITY. AND FOR THE BUILDING
OF STABLE FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA
AND OUR FAMILIES. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE. THANK YOU
TO WITNESSES AND SOME. IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NINE. I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THE MODERATOR TO
OPEN THE PUBLIC PHONE LINE UP
FOR SUPPORT TESTIMONY WE WILL
ASK ALLOW THE FIRST FIVE CARS
TESTIFIED FOR ONE MINUTE EACH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY CUED UP TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
FOR TO OPEN A LINE OF WHY
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS VANESSA ARE MARIO AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LINE THE BETTER COMMUNITY AND
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT ONE
MICRON SUPPORT OF THIS
INITIATIVE NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE NEED TO FIND A CENTRAL LOCAL
SERVICES LIKE FIRST RESPONDERS
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT KATIE
CLINICS. IT'LL BE TWELVE AND
THE COLLEGE AGE. IT ALSO BEING
HUGE HISTORIC CUTS AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SUPPORT
THE NEW IT WHICH WILL HELP
BRING TRYING MUCH BY THE TWELVE
BILLION TO OUR BOB STUDENTS TO
OUR LOW WHO WANT. TO CRITICAL
VITAL HUMAN SERVICES AT RT
THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN THE LINE
NUMBER OF LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I'M MY NAME
IS STEVEN ROADIE I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
pI PRACTICE LAW IN LOS ANGELES
FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS AND BEEN
ACTIVE IN COMMUNITY AFFAIRS I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE SCARE
TACTICS THAN IT'S AN ARGUMENT
THAT THE OPPONENTS ARE MAKING
COOL THANK YOU THE FIRST IS.
FOR IS IT IN. TAX RELIEF FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND EXAMS ALL
SMALL BUSINESSES. PRETTY IS
WORTH THREE MILLION DOLLARS OR
LESS. NEARLY HALF OF SMALL
BUSINESSES OUR HOME BASE. AND
SINCE THIS INITIATIVE EXAMS ALL
HOMEOWNERS THEY WOULD BE
COMPLETELY DOWN. I'M ALSO VERY
CONCERNED TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
LIBRARY I RAISED THREE KIDS IN
LOS ANGELES WE DO NEED INTERNET
FOR ALL WE NEED TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC LIBRARY FOR FIVE SECONDS
AND ONLINE LEARNING. THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT DURING THE COLD
BUT NINETEEN CRISIS AS WE
SUPPORT COMMUNITY SERVICE THANK
YOU SIR. ALL. AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS MICHELLE RICHARD AND I
REPRESENT THE LIBERTY HEALTH
FOUNDATION IN LOS ANGELES WE
STAND WITH SEVEN OTHER PUBLIC
FOUNDATIONS AND GRAPHIC THIS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE JUST GO
TO EAT THEY SELL CON VALLEY TO
LOS ANGELES AND THEN LET YOU
KNOW COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
URGING SUPPORT FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY FIRST. I IN TUITION
BUNCH YOU SERVICES AND HOW CARE
AT. AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ALL AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE KNOW THAT
OUR SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
CRYING OUT FOR THE RESOURCES
THIS BALLOT MEASURE WILL
PROVIDE. THEY AND WE CANNOT
STRESS ENOUGH TO MEET THE
TOONAMI APPROVING NEEDS WITHOUT
PAYING. THOSE WHO WILL PAY THE
PATH THE BAND COULD GET THAT
THE BEST A BOTH THE LOCAL.
THANK FIVE SECOND READING THAT
URGENTLY NEED. THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO OPEN MY NUMBER OF LINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR MIND IS NOW OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS BECKY- I LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN IN. OR
HEARING OUR MESSAGE I'M WITH
LOCAL ONE TWO ONE ARE IN I LIVE
IN TOWARD AND I'M THE POINT OF
A NEW THAT I'M SPEAKING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE FRONTLINE
WORKERS. FROM MY HEELS IN THE
CRISIS THE NEW SERVICE IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN
MUCH OF WHICH IS OPERATED AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL FOUNDED WHICH
CASH WHAT WHAT. ARE YOUR- NOW
THE BUDGETS HAVE BEEN FOR APART.
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS IN YOUR
DOCTOR. HAVE ON THE FRONTLINE
OF THE- FLIGHT AND THEY HAVE
WORTH ALIVE ALL OF IT SHAMEFUL
THAT CAL. YEAH ECONOMY IN THE-
AND YET OUR HEALTHCARE WORKERS
NOT HAVE RESOURCE TO PICK THEM.
THEY ARE OFTEN FORCED TO RELY
ON DONATED. FIVE SECONDS WE CAN
DO BETTER THAN THAT. AND I AM
ONE OF THOSE WORK IT'S TIME TO
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE FOR THE MOST
THANK YOU CORPORATION. BUT
BEING YOU OUR LAST WITNESS ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT OPEN
LINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THERE
THANK YOU I'M TERRY ONLY WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS INITIATIVE. ON THE CURRENT
SYSTEM COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
NOT REASSESS UNLESS UNDER SHIP
CHANGES AND WE KNOW THAT LARGE
PUBLICLY TRADED CORPORATIONS
RARELY CHANGE OWNERSHIP WHICH
MEANS THAT WE HAVE. OUR OWN
BIKE INCREDIBLY- PROFITABLE
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE NEVER
EFFECTIVELY RHEOSTAT. IN FACT
CHEVRON INTEL AND IBM OWN LAND
STILL UPSET AT NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE VALUES WHILE NEARBY LAND
THAT THE FIFTY TIMES THE VALUE
OR MORE IT MAKES NO LOGICAL
SENSE TO MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM.
AND IMPORTANTLY THE CURRENT
SYSTEM HAS TO IMPACT THE HARM
LOCAL COMMUNITY FIRST STATE
LARGE CORPORATIONS TO CREATE AN
UNLEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
SMALLER BUSINESSES TO COMPETE.
SECOND IT OFF RIGHT LOCAL
COMMUNITY OF THE CHARGES NEEDED
TO INVEST IN THE VERY THING WE
ALL BENEFIT. GOOD SCHOOL I
THANK. PROGRAMS LIKE. HEALTH
HOSPITALS AND PARK NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE TO SEE A FUNDING
GO TO OUR- COMMUNITIES THAT
MAKE A STATE AND THRIVING AND
COMMUTING. TO LIVE IN THANK YOU.
GREATER PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINE TO ADDITIONAL IN
INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
INITIATIVE I WOULD ASK THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY. THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER OF LINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS A GENE WIDER AND
I'MA MEMBER. OF THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS IN SAN DIEGO AND I
SUPPORT THE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY FIRST INITIATIVE VERY
SLOWLY- I'M A RETIRED
HOMEOWNERS AND I HAVE
BENEFITTED. FROM TABLE PAYMENT
AFFILIATION ON THAT PLEASE. I'M
SORRY OKAY THANK YOU MIGHT
THINK. THANK THANK YOU. AND
NEXT TO OPEN MY UMBER TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS HERE IN FLORIDA I AM
A RETIRED HOMEOWNERS CAN
CAMPING SO STRONG WITH THE
FORTUNATE SHOULD IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN LINE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR. ONE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN HI-
MY NAME IS CONNIE I LIVE IN
SANTA CLARA ALAMEDA COUNTY AND-
SANTA AND WORKING SANTA CLARA
COUNTY I SUPPORT SCHOOL THE
COMMUNITY FIRST WHICH WILL
BRING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
CRITICAL LOCAL STEVEN
AFFILIATION I'M GOING UP IN THE
SEVENTIES I REMEMBER HAVING BUT
SING TO. MY THANK YOU IN NAME
AND AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE.
AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER ONE TWO
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
ACTUALLY I NEED TO SPEAK ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE I APOLOGIZE I
DIDN'T TO SEND. AND NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME LAKE FOREST WITHOUT ACT
OF CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE
SCHOOLS IN THE FIRST INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT OPEN LINEUP.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS WILLIAM STRIP BUT I'M
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
ALAMEDA AND I SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL COMMITTEES FIRST
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LIKE BY. SUSAN
BROWN OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THAT COMING
OUT. DO SUPPORT THE FIRST MATCH
THANK YOU THINKING. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY FIVE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONLY TRUE
HERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN SHE. HELLO
CHRIS FAMILY. OBJECTION IT IS
BETTER AND I SUPPORT THE
PROPOSITION WE NEED TO GO
FORWARD. YOU MAKING IT. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
OUR MONDO TEETH ON THE ORDER TO
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR FOR
EMPOWERING THAT IN A FUTURE THE
COMMITTEES FIRST. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY CRUISER WITH
ABOUT THE PROJECT HEALTH POINT
INTRO THE MEASURE WHICH BE KEY
TO BORDER. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
TO OPEN MY NUMBER ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS MAKE YOU REMAIN AT THE ARE
YOU LOOK ONE THOUSAND THE FORCE
WILL BE THE FIRST THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO OPEN.
WHEN MY NAME IS MICHAEL SO
WHILE I'M EMERGENCY MEDICINE
WILL CONDITION AT HARBOR UCLA A
LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTER AND
COUNTY HOSPITAL REPRESENTING
THE I. R. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INITIATIVE. THANK
YOU. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VERONICA CUTTING SALAS AND I'M
WITH CALIFORNIA CALLED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FIRST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT ALTER MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
IMPRESSED WITH INNER CITY
STRUGGLING WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
OR THINKING READ FIRST THANK
YOU THANK. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY THIS
JERRY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT PROP
PROPOSITION ISSUE SCHOOLS
COMMUNITIES FIRST FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS GREG BRANCH AND THE TEACHER
AN ATTORNEY REPRESENTING W. T.
WHAT IS YOUR TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I SUPPORT THIS.
INITIATIVE THANK YOU. NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YEAH MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY SHOVEL ON I'M
A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
THE INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS KATHY RAWLINGS AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CULT THAT SCHOOL
BOARD AND THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SCHOOLS IN COMMITTEE
FIRST. THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS BRIAN O'NEILL AT SEA
ARE YOU OUT BY TWO ONE RETIREE
FROM THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S OFFICE. AND I WISH I
COULD SPEAK BUT I CAN'T I HEART
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY FIRST THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO. HI MY NAME IS
WENDY GREEN FIELD I WORK IN
EDUCATION FOR THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS BEFORE RETIRING AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND PART OF
THAT THE LOTUS LEFT THE
FOUNDATION NETWORK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FOR. THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YEAH ANY HARM I'M A
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WAS AFFILIATED
WITH BENNY ARCSERVE **** XIN
THE JEWS COMMITTED TO POSITIVE
CHANGE. STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE
WHERE BE JUDGED BY HOW WE HELP
THOSE AMONG US MOST IN NAME
ONLY THESE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TAMMY
SHELTON I'M ON- ELEMENTARY
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER I LIVE IN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY LOW
FAT I'M A YOUTH LEADER WITH
SURE A LOT AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF THE COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS
JACKIE GROWING YEAH W. I
FRANKLY HELPFUL AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HEY AT NINE THAT THE
POWER CALIFORNIA AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG VOTERS
WITH THE TRUNK THE CORPORATE
FOR THE COMMUNITY FOR MEDIUM
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS AGNES
BRAGA I AM FROM AT THE ARE YOU
LOCAL NINETY NINE IN LOS
ANGELES AND IT STRONG SUPPORT
OF SCHOOL THE COMMUNITIES FIRST.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEDICAL ONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX REFORM THE ASIAN INSTRUCT
THE COURT THE NATURE. THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS CONSTANTINE
HATCHER REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
BR EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS INITIATIVE
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI AM PRACTICAL
CLARK I'M A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY FIRST FINISH IT UP I
THINK YOU. LINE AND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BURKE CHAIR IDEA CREAM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANUAL BUT HE
GETS ON BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION
TRUST WIFE WHO WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SCHOOL TO
COMMITTEE FIRST LISTED. THANK
YOU. LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS THAT ORDER
FOR TIA AT THE LATINO COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION A STATE WHAT FILM
PROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED IN
SAN FRANCISCO WE SUPPORT THE
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MONEY THAT'S
RELEASE POLICY IN WITH CHIRLA
AND PERFORMANCE OF COUNTY AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SCHOOLS AND COMMITTEES FIRST
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TITLE THIS WORKED OUT OF
THE BOOK THE WORST PART OF
FOUNDATION AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF THE LISTING WHAT CHILDREN
YES WE SUPPORT SCHOOL THE
COMMUNITIES FIRST. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
HERMAN AND I'M WITH THE LEGAL
NAY VOTERS AND RANCHO CALIPERS
THE PART OF LA COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT- SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES FIRST. THANK YOU.
I'M READY TO DOMINATE A
REMINDER IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
HAVE BEEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
NEXT TO GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE ONE
THE SITUATION HANDLED FROM THE.
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT LOVE ALL. THANK YOU ONE
ONE SIX. LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JOSH WELL ON A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER COMING GRAN
YOUR DAY IN A VOLUNTEER
SIGNATURE GATHER IN SUPPORT OF
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY SERVICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS READY FOR
LAMAR ALEXANDER FORMER AND
FIRST LATINO MAYOR OF THE CITY
PARTLY NINI AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE UNITED PRACTICING
ABOUT CONNIE BECAUSE WE SUPPORT
SCHOOLS INCOMING. THANK YOU.
YOU AND AT THIS TIME WE SHOULD
KNOW WHEN OFFICE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. I THINK I WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUT OF OPPOSITION TESTIMONIO
RECOGNIZE UP TO FIVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE GALLERY FOR
US TO ONE MINUTE. OPPOSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
BESTER AND FOR TWELVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN RESEARCHING SCHOOL
FUNDING. I AM EXCUSE ME MA'AM
WE- I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
SOMEONE THERE TO HELP HER WITH
THE MIKE. NO ALL RIGHT YOU JUST
MAY HAVE TO SPEAK LOUDER. THERE
YOU GO. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MY NAME IS JENNIFER BESTER AND
FOR TWELVE YEARS I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING SCHOOL FUNDING FROM
THE GROUND UP WITH ONLY ONE
GOAL IN MIND TO GET MORE STABLE
RELIABLE PROPERTY TAX INTO
THESE SCHOOLS SADLY I AM HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS.
INITIATIVE FOR ONE PRIMARY
REASON FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
IT REMOVES PROPERTY TAX FROM
THE COUNTY IN WHICH IT WAS
RAZED. THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR TRANSPARENCY TO
PARENTS AND VOTERS IN THESE
COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF NEW PROPERTY TAX
WOULD BE LEVIED HER SCHOOL
CHILD. BUT THE CHILD'S SCHOOL
WOULD ONLY GET SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS 25% OF THE
NEW REVENUE WOULD BE REMOVED
FOR ELSEWHERE. IN MY COUNTY SAN
MATTEO SIX THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED WOULD BE RAISED. ONLY
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY DOLLARS
PER SCHOOL CHILD WOULD GO TO
THE SCHOOLS HALF OF OUR NEW
REVENUE GOES ELSEWHERE
SIMILARLY SANTA CLARA. THERE
ARE THIRTEEN FIVE SECONDS.
PLEASE THAT WOULD BE DONORS. I
CALL ON PROPONENTS TO BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE EFFECTS
IN EACH AND EVERY COUNTY THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
UP IN THE GALLERY. SCENE NINE.
I WOULD ASK THAT WOULD NOT THE
MODERATOR TO OPEN THE PUBLIC
PHONE LINES FOR TESTAMENT
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ONLY WE
WILL OF THE FIRST FIVE DOLLARS
TO TESTIFY FOR UP TO ONE MINUTE.
GENTLEMAN IF YOU'RE NOT ALREADY
CUTER PROPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FIRST OFF IN A LINE OF SIX ONE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY I'M MY NAME IS
CHUCKLING HARD ON THE PLUMAS
COUNTY ASSESSOR AND I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AND I THINK IT
CREATES AN UNFUNDED MANDATE AND
RURAL COUNTIES. AND IT'S GOING
TO BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR RURAL
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT. THANK
YOU. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER ONE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
WELL WHICH PEOPLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION UP FIRST WE'D LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY THE PLAYER FIND
THE ONLY- BE IMPACT THIS
INITIAL THAT WILL HAVE. A
CALIFORNIA FARMERS RANCHERS. TO
ECHO WHAT THE L. A. L. A. O. HE
SAID IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS ARE BARNES
OUR VINEYARDS WINERY SPENCE'S.
IRRIGATION SYSTEM SMOKING
PARLORS AND EVEN ARE MATURE NOT
TREES WILL BE TAXED AT FAIR
MARKET VALUE UNDER THIS
INITIATIVE. CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN A THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OPPOSED TO
FINISH IT THANK YOU. YEAH. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY NAME IS
GEORGE WHEN I'M BEST PRESIDENT
SOLANO COUNTY- TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION CURRENT MEMBER. I
AGREE WITH THE GIANT KOPPEL AND
THE ASSESSORS PHONE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S DIES TAX- STATE IN
THE COUNTRY WE NEED A LOT LESS
TAXES A LOT MORE EFFICIENCY WE
NEED TO GET RID OF ALL THESE
PEOPLE AT ONE AWAY SIR TAX
MONEY USES TOO MUCH HAS BEEN
WASTED NO DOUBT NO RESULTS
SINCE TIME. TO IN THIS WAY IT
AND START ALL AGAIN. AND GET
BACK TO THE THEY OPENED THE
OPPOSE TO EVERYBODY SOUL WOULD
CALL OF THAT- NEVER PODUCES IN
RESULTS OF. IT THIS PLACE IS
GOING BANKRUPT AND THERE'S NOT
GONNA BE ANYBODY TO PAY THE
TAXES FOR REASONS TOO MANY
LEFTIST PEOPLE RUN IN THE STATE
ONE. PARTY GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
WORK YOU GET OUT OF- BELIEVES
TWO PARTIES. SO I REALLY HOPE
THAT THIS NONSENSE. FIVE
SECONDS THE QUICK. SO LOW
PLEASE BE SURE VOTE BIG FOR THE
TO ADD THANK VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. AND AT THE TIME I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. KING.
THE WHOLE SYSTEM. KUTCHER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO HAVE ANY CLOSING
STATEMENTS. NO I LEARNED BY
LIKE TWO ABSOLUTELY THANK
EVERYONE THE PARTICIPATE TODAY-
I LEARNED A FEW THINGS AND I
HOPE THEY LEARNED A FEW THINGS
FOR ME AS WELL- I APPRECIATE
THEM THE YOUR COMMITTEE PUTTING
THIS ALL TOGETHER. WE HAVE A
LOT F WORK TO DO IN THE TRYING
COUPLE WEEKS AND- SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU TO MY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU A JURY
MCDONALD WAS WELL. AND I THINK
TO EVERYONE FOR BEING I THANK
YOU TO OUR MODERATOR ON THE
PHONE FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
SERVICE AND TO THOSE WHO WERE
ENDING HERE IN COMMITTEE WITH
THEIR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
THEY WERE MORE. NATIONAL WITH.
THIS.